[Music]
welcome everybody to the speed Chess
Championship this is the second match of
the day I'm Grandmaster Daniel nitzki
alongside me today International Master
Casa Corley Casa good afternoon to you
hey hey da good to be with you for a
really exciting match it's going to be
an amazing battle between two of the top
American players carar Nakamura and
Fabiano Carana but there's been exciting
matches all around let's take a look at
our bracket to start off the show man we
just watched an incredible match between
Yanna pishi and arjin arayi Kasa it's
been a mouthwatering display no matter
where you look yeah I mean just these
matches come right down to the wires
sometimes and I mean we just saw a
thriller with nepo taking it right at
the last moment and I'm expecting
another really tough match today so
really looking forward to it indeed you
can see there the quarterfinals match up
between hiar Nakamura and Fabiano Carana
and of course we also have nihal against
mvl that will come later but today is
all about two of the most recognizable
players in chess history let's have a
look at our deoe game analytics Kasa
what really jumps out at me is that they
actually haven't played all that many
games between themselves
online yeah it's actually quite peculiar
I mean you know these guys have been the
Giants of American chess for many many
years now and uh yeah it appears they
don't have so much online experience but
we we both know their games and uh we
know hakar is an absolute Monster uh in
fast time controls particularly on
jess.com
Fabiano has also been a much improved
rapid and Blitz player and I think he
you know remains underrated he
absolutely does he also leads their
Blitz head-to-head despite the obvious
disparity in their chess.com Blitz
rating as we look at the second page of
our deloid game analytics the bullet
rating disparity is crazy
3570 that does not sound like a number
that can correspond to chess rating Kasa
yeah it's kind of absurd and I think
that's actually going to set the tone
for kind of the keys to success in this
match because if Fabiano really wants to
take this he's going to have to do his
work early he most certainly will Hikaru
is such a good bullet player and for
Hikaru he hasn't really tried all that
hard in the openings he's just tried to
get interesting positions and outplay
his opponents in the middle game across
all time controls but we are getting
started here hikaro with the white
pieces in the first game and is
surprised as early as move one Kasa
Hikaru starting with
1c3 yeah these early C3 I expect
something that you know transposes
toward a London um maybe we'll have a
bishop come out to F4 maybe to G5 if a
car is feeling frisky but no okay we
have this queen B3 sighting and here we
go and we've transposed entirely into a
more respectable opening if I didn't see
the first move I would think that this
is some sort of a queen Gambit declined
or maybe if a pawn appears on C6 a slav
so the move C3 isn't as bad as people
make it out to be most of the time it
just transposes into a more ventional
opening yeah 100% And the real question
here for white now is do you want to Fan
Shadow your Bishop on G2 or do you want
to put it to E3 I expect G3 Bishop G2
happening shortly and Fabiano's
potentially inviting some B5 push down
the line but a fanetta would discourage
that I agree completely instead Hikaru
develops his other bishop and puts it on
F4 obviously the C7 Pawn is now Under
Fire and the conventional way of
responding here I think would be C7 C D5
but it's a pretty committal move
especially because your queen is
currently unprotected so you're not
going to be threatening C takes D4 in
that position it's already a direct
confrontation and so Fabby invests a
little bit of time here uh C5 is not the
kind of move you play willy-nilly
yeah and my impression though is that
that's really going to be the question
if if black gets in C5 and no we've seen
Knight C6 so I was going to say black
gets in C5 black probably equalizes if
not White's going to have a slight
Advantage based upon the pawn do in the
center a little bit more space and so uh
Fab's going to be a little bit worse
here for a while oh absolutely I think
Knight C6 is already in admission that
he doesn't love his position Robert
likes to say the side that controls the
pawn breaks controls the position the
only Pawn break that I see now uh for
black is an eventual E6 E5 but with
White's Bishop sitting on F4 White's
controlling that score a bunch of times
even if black plays Bishop D6 which I
think is very likely hikaro can just
drop his Bishop back to G3 and then
proceed with his kingside development
and it will be very very difficult for
black logistically uh to organize the E5
Pawn break I think we're going to see
that play out right now yeah no question
there's also this potential Juke with
Bishop G5 that you'll see in some
structures you you can consider Bishop
G5 consider capturing on F6 or at least
tease the idea and I like what white has
done thus far because even though the
bishop on F1 is not developed black
remains cramped and you know now the
queen on C8 is a bit misplaced the n on
C6 is misplaced and uh we're already
getting hakaru faces uh he's kind of
figuring out where to go with that
Bishop yeah now that you pointed it out
I'm looking over at at my other screen
here thinking very very deeply I don't
know if he's surprised necessarily by
how Fabby has handled the opening but
given his first move he's got to be
happy uh at the outcome of the first 10
moves or so Bishop G3 Bishop G5 I think
is a lovely idea just threatening Bishop
takes F6 maybe he's calculating Bishop
G5 and then the Knight can jump out to
E4 or you could even play Bishop to E
which is a much weirder move but instead
he goes with a fourth idea G3 I was
literally about to say G3 da because
it's such a you know typical catalon
idea where you have this sort of weird
structure with a double Pawn double F
pawns Pawn E3 and it's a very very
compact position and just further
reinforces uh you know the E5 square at
least preventing that push that liberate
liberating push for black so and then in
some positions you can even entertain
some some Rook G1 Dynamics down the road
so another way to keep the tension and I
think it's you know regardless we're
never going to see Bishop takes
D6 agree and instead we saw Bishop takes
F4 now we could spend the entire show
enumerating hikaru's various strengths
across Blitz uh and bullet but one of
those strengths is his ability to pose
practical decisions to his opponent he
gets everybody in such serious time
pressure and the way that he does it is
he makes these open-ended moves
particularly in the early middle game
and he forces his opponent to make a lot
of difficult decisions here with a move
G3 that was one decision Fabby had to
make whether to keep the tension or to
take on F4 he's decided to exchange the
Bishops now hikaro has this clamp on the
E5 square and he's just established a
knight on E5 and Kasa we're very likely
to see the move E3 to solidify the F4
Pawn Yeah you know something one thing I
will give Fabby credit for though is he
is slightly up on the clock which is
going to be important and he does play
the Black side of these catalon
structures a lot um he played at the
World Cup against abos off that didn't
go so well but he has a a great depth of
experience here and so you know if
you're playing the black side of these
positions you're thinking a lot about
how to liberate your queen side with a
B5 or C5 Pawn break so um I think at
least he's unaware of the terms and
conditions yeah he definitely is and
Hikaru now with a decision to make the
F4 Pawn is hanging you can't give that
one away Knight takes G6 it would appear
to me would kind of defeat the purpose
of hikaru's play then why did you
establish a knight on E5 but one thing
that might be giving hikaro pause is
that E3 runs into this weird looking
move Knight H4 and this bishop doesn't
have any squares along the long diagonal
to to stay on it might have to drop back
to F1 that's a bit of an awkward move
then you're you're preventing yourself
from castling Kasa so I think that Fabby
should pounce on the opportunity because
if you let hikaro Castle or even play
Rook G1 then white will be able to drop
the bishop back to H1 good stuff by
Fabby
yeah I agree 100% And I think actually
if you have Knight takes G2 happen
you'll feel you might be able to get
away with B5 and maybe something like
Queen B7 or B5 even C5 tactically at
times um I mean you feel reluctant to
ever get in C5 with the Rook bearing
down in you but sometimes there's some
you can sort of get that break off and
even as a temporary Pawn sacrifice
that's kind of what I would be looking
at is trying to to liberate on the queen
side in a really tactical way from
White's perspective Ive I think the
reason hikaro went for that G3 G takes
F4 idea is to get that g file cracked
open and apply direct pressure on the G7
Pawn now you need more you need more
beef on the king side if you want to do
that so one way of involving a second
Rook is to play King E2 and then Rook C
to G1 but that could end up as a dead
end black could drop the bishop back to
G6 maybe then white could send that H
Pawn up the board so I'm really curious
to see how Hikaru is going to organize
his kingside play he could also drop his
Knight back let's say to E2 Casa and
apply pressure on the C7 Pawn so it's
not only black who can play on the king
side white can actually on the queen
side that is white can play on both
sides of the board here yeah and that's
really the flexibility in this position
for white and there are a lot of
positions now where this King might
actually just stay in the center just
come up to E2 or even D2 under the right
circumstances and then all of a sudden
white is primed and ready for any type
of catalon end game where again the grip
in the center particularly on the E5 and
C5 squares is going to be problematic
for black in the long term and so I
think black still has to do some work
here to essentially equalize but or you
know keep the game going in in a
reasonable way because it's not going to
be easy and for hikaro I think he's
gotten what he wanted out of the opening
kind of a fresh independent position
he's recaptured there on E5 with the
with the Deep hun away from the center
obviously newer players are advised to
capture toward the center that Al
relinquishes the grip on the C5 Square
so black could if he so desired now play
C7 C5 but I feel like the purpose of
that move is kind of defeated when
there's no Pawn on D4 to challenge and
hikaro drops the Knight back to E2 we
mentioned this move Casa he hits C7
still looking like a pretty dynamically
balanced position as the clocks for both
sides dwindle to a minute and the
Contour the Contours of the game are
starting to take shape basically black
is going to have the long-term trumps
the the queen ins side Paul majority to
three on two is a decided Advantage the
bishop longterm might be better than the
knight in some in a lot of circumstances
in the short term white has a potential
initiative on the king side and if white
is not able to prosecute that initiative
black is going to feel pretty good and
it's hard to prosecute it because black
has control a monopoly over the light
Square so this bishop on G6 is solid as
a rock white can go H4 congrats but
you're not really going to go H5 and
Fabby there he briefly sacrificed the C7
pawn it was very very scary to capture
it because that would have popped open
the SE file and now Hikaru kind of
clustering up with a knight on D4 fa
getting his pieces into the center now
C5 looks really really appealing so you
would want to prepare it with a move
like B6 but hikaro will immediately
stick his Queen on C6 so it's much
easier said than done yeah king of one
is really an admission of guilt the
strategy has not worked out on the king
side and you know again these split
Rooks The Rook on G3 The Rook on C1 it's
really going to be problematic uh the
the longer this this continues so yeah
Fab starting to take over and the time
is going to be a factor it most
certainly is fabbi has to keep his
composure in time pressure situations
Hikaru is so good at posing practical
problems when his opponents fall to
under 30 seconds now both sides at 30
seconds this is a very exciting first
game an exchange of Pawns on B4 and
there it is B6 by Fabby preparing C7 C5
hikaro could push his Pawn to B5 and he
does will we see an exchange sack kasak
Corley Style no he puts his Rook on D5
instead yeah it's funny you kind of
would like to put the Knight on C6 but
it's actually more important to just
block the defile for Black's Rooks right
now and so fab is trying to figure out
how to enter maybe Rook A8 at the right
moment although you're you're worried
about the C7 Pawn constantly but I'd
expect uh The Rook on C8 to get active
somehow maybe black to give them sou lft
and Bishop D3 check escapes the G file
and Fabby grabs the pawn up B5 but this
is what Hikaru does F5 great practical
move and suddenly that initiative we
talked about on the king side it's
getting cracked open Knight takes F5
Rook D1 check and he missed that
check Rook takes C1 and queen E4 should
win the
game Rook takes C1 here is the winning
move but he's got to not fear Rook takes
G7 scary looking move and f8 or h8 I I
mean I'd probably go to f8 and there's
no more check there and black has this
Fork on e4 which is what Hikaru missed
all right E6 is a good practical try uh
5 seconds left for
both Queen takes B5 no he takes Bop
bishop or Bishop B2 even better yeah
yeah that's a wrap that's a wrap Queen
takes F3 is checkm in three moves and
Fabby takes the first
one yeah both of them are a little bit
uh miffed at what just happened but uh
Fabiano got the point and he can be very
very happy this is is a critical
juncture for him he needs to be up on
the clock and separate a little bit here
uh as we get faster and faster we know
car is gonna get the advantage agreed I
think a lot of people are are expecting
this to be a blowout and underestimating
you know the new Fabiana Carana but
you're totally right if Fabby wants a
chance at this he's got to get that lead
in the fem minute portion hikaro playing
one A6 in the second game and owens's
hybrid we can say because then you
follow it up with E6 is pretty wild so
uh the you know okay A3 is pretty modest
uh da I would just have gone Knight F3
to Bishop D3 I'm not a huge fan of this
A3 move yeah A3 is kind of a sign that
Fabby isn't trying too hard to punish
hikaro for playing one A6 I I still like
White's position you've got this Bon
style Pawn that just appeared on D5
hearu takes it allowing a knight to
established itself on defa shocking um
yeah white white definitely has a
massive Ed here e takes D5 uh would be
my choice just to maintain the space But
even Queen takes D5 is is sufficient and
White's going to have the two Bishops
and space uh you like those like those
things although what I don't like about
Fab's position here is the clock he has
to keep himself up on the clock so that
when the scrambles do happen uh and that
confusion that uh hakara creates comes
on the board he's ready but we have a
very nice bononi style structure here
for white for sure your point is well
taken I think in the last game Fabby did
a great job he left himself with with
just enough time so that when Hikaru
blundered that check on D1 you know he
he didn't have five seconds he had 25
seconds that is the chief difference as
Fabby tries to get his knight from H4 to
F5 and obviously hikaro could prevent
that with G6 but his position is already
very flimsy and kind of riddled with
positional weaknesses creating more of
them on the king side doesn't seem very
advisable so I think hiar is just kind
of going to bite the bullet in Castle
and allow F5 and and try to kind of work
around that Knight and maybe get his own
knight from D7 over to E5 potentially or
or B6 yeah to be honest I'm actually not
a huge fan of this Knight H4 Knight F5
maneuver simply because uh White needed
just a few moves to connect the Rooks
and and maintain space and now you know
Naka is pretty good with his Knights
particularly in these fast controls so I
would have preferred a combination of
Bishop F4 and Rook E1 although Knight E8
is extremely puzzling and I think Knight
takes E7 and queen takes E7 and Rook E1
here is extremely compelling white has
the two Bishops more space and you could
even see scenarios where the queen comes
to A4 and it's hard for the black queen
side to develop because C6 becomes a
weakness if the Knight Knight on B8
comes to D7 the D6 Pawn is soft very
tough circumstance but this is the best
of both worlds Bishop on F4 Knight on F5
this is kind of what I was looking at
the Knight on F3 and of course Fabby
ignoring the B2 Pawn technically I don't
think there's a direct reputation Bishop
takes B2 but hikaru's got bigger fish to
fry he needs to complete his development
here he can't rip open the queen side
because White's Rook is then going to
land on B7 he gives up the D6 Pawn Fabby
says thank you very much I'll grab it
and what does hearo have in mind here
Knight
B6 yeah but even if Fabby just plays
primitively and KN plays Knight takes C8
I mean he's going to emerge I think with
an extra Pawn for minimal to no
compensation and what a pawn it is a
passer on D5 yeah and again this PA on
B2 which is hanging is just so
inconsequential in this position right
now there's just too much action
happening in the middle and you
essentially jump start that Rook on A1
uh if you went for it so yeah this is
this is already uh non ideal um yeah
this is this is just a tough spot for
for black right now if black if white
ever gets in D6 da it's gonna be a RP
absolutely if D6 is played and of course
right now the bishop is hanging so big
decision for Fabby does he drop it back
to A2 or back down this diagonal he
brings it back to E2 So eventually he
wants to play Bishop F3 right if you
give him one more move the game is
basically over so hikaro has to take
this brief opportunity that he has to
play either a move like Queen E4 and the
sad thing for blacka is that even if
black wins back the D5 Pawn White's got
other assets that he can hang his hat on
Black's got weaknesses on the queen side
White's got the bishop pair White's got
the better placed pieces so I like what
Hikaru is doing he grabs the pawn on B2
and he's going to meet Rook B1 think
with Knight to A4 he's hanging by a
thread but I don't see a direct win in
that position with Knight C3 looming
large over White's position yeah it's
it's stunning geometry because it it
does feel like everything's hanging by a
thread but I'm still my my Spide senses
are tingling and frankly I I just the n
on A4 is does not seem ideal unless it
lands on C3 but tough to stop now tough
to stop now yeah I don't love Fab's last
move there Queen C2 forced the bishop
but it wants to be on D4 anyway now the
bishop at least is stable it's supported
by a pawn the Knight is going to be a
lot more stable if it reaches C3 and it
just did Bobby moves his Rook over to C1
but now there are no more threats and
Hikaru can work on improving his
position ultimately on disarming this
Pawn on D5 so maybe a move like Rook d8
uh can be considered now white should
still be better here with his excellent
Bishop placement and maybe the move
Bishop C7 should be considered here yeah
100% Bishop C7 and then D6 and you kind
of oh he it's just the wrong move order
Bishop C7 first and then D6 and then the
pawn would have been nicely uh secured
two squares from the queen from the
queening square on d8 this version is
not as ideal although I will say uh
there's still I think a quite high
margin for error here for white and I
don't see it being too too dangerous
just yet unless the D6 Pawn is locked
off for free I agree and I think Fabby
ensuring that it won't be locked off for
free he attacks it counterattacks I
should say the A6 Pawn if we could pull
up an analysis board really quickly just
to show people why it was so important
to throw in the move Bishop C7 after
Rook D7 D6 if black does the exact same
thing Knight B5 there's an alignment of
the rook and the Queen and white has
this additional resource Bishop to C6
pinning The Rook to the queen let's say
black plays Knight takes C7 white
doesn't even have to hurry with taking
the Rook D takes C7 and The Rook on D7
is lost this would have led to a losing
position for black that was a winning
move for Fabby he missed it and now we
go back to the live board hikaro has
finally gotten rid of that D6 Pawn Fabby
can now trade queens and play a pawn
down or Kasa he can take on A6 and
reestablish material equality which he's
chosen to do but this is getting a
little bit scary yeah and again the F2
square is sensitive and I think for the
longest time uh Fab's needed to you get
in G3 and King G2 and he had actually
hasn't found the time to do it and this
is basically the worst version of these
opposite colge Bishop end games because
F2 is going to be a permanent Target and
so I actually think this is going to be
a tough hold now because the King on G1
is just a little bit weaker or actually
I'd say significantly weaker than the
black counterpart this is a terrible
position for Fabby and it's really
frustrating that he even has to defend
this given how good his position was
just a couple of moves ago it seems
Hikaru is probably going to make makes
himt he's got all the Time in the World
to play moves like G6 and H5 and maybe
King G7 the same idea that Fabby uh
wanted to carry out in order to prevent
what we currently have from being on the
board so still a lot of practical
chances for white but he's under a
minute and how many times have we seen
Hikaru squeezing you know these small to
medium advantages uh in his opponent's
low time yeah you have to be up on the
clock uh when the Skirmish happens uh
particularly when you're playing against
a sakaro and again this G6 move for
folks at home when youve a uh you're
trying to figure make an escape Square
you make the Escape Square on the
opposite color as the opponent's Bishop
so that you just are very very secure
and so you see white is a light squared
Bishop black makes a dark squared Escape
Square conversely much ear in the game
we wanted to see G3 uh to give that
light Square on G2 to deal with this
dark Square Bishop but here we go F2 is
now being pressed uh Rook F1 just too
much passivity here and yeah Rook F2
Queen E1 a rra that's just wins on the
spot Rook takes after hearo he left
himself with two minutes he's in no
hurry and this is basic Brian right here
he's not going to miss these easy
tactics and the problem isn't that white
loses a pawn that could not be further
uh from importance the problem is that
the king is now just getting hunted down
with a series of checks Queen G1 uh you
could even play Queen E3 and queen H6
that's some lovely geometry uh that we
might see on the board hikaro has all
the Time in the World to figure this out
and then and again even here the dark
squares they're they're basically swiss
cheese in White's position I mean
they're just not getting covered
whatsoever even Bishop takes G3 and even
even Queen even end games now with
obstacle Bishops with this amount of
Pawns is going to be enough to win but I
think Naka given the time Advantage will
look for more yeah he might I think he's
gonna play Queen E5 and the interesting
thing there is that white can't
technically get the queen around to H4
but in that resulting position black
still has this little baby on C
that he could send down the board but
iar does something similar he took on G3
first now he plays Queen E5 and he's
going to I mean like you said Kasa the
the even the bishop endgame is probably
winning with three extra pawns or no two
extra pawns but still I would probably
keep the Queens on the board though
anytime the Queens get swapped you get
that tiny inkling of opportunity that
maybe white can set up some sort of a
blockade it's definitely a matter of
taste da and you're you're a tactical
guy I would just be very very happy to
just trade queens and consolidate
there's no chance here of the white
Bishop holding all of the pawns together
and uh the bishop could have landed on
C7 comfortably but yeah manting is going
to be the faster route no question and
he's just eliminated Fab's only pride of
his position the A5 pun just don't go H5
and blunder G6 with check yeah that
would be that would be sad but hikaro
doing a great job here no stalemate
tricks yeah it's over there we go and
he's leveled the score and queen G3 and
queen H2 were problematic there so no
reason to continue but that game this oh
my gosh we have H3 now from knockup that
the story of that game was the time
situation Fab had an excellent position
I dare say winning at in that early
middle game but he slipped under a
minute and then two minutes and then you
know just Cascades in the wrong
direction he has to stay up on the clock
for the eminent time scrambles you're
totally right that was an infuriating
game it it was essentially plus two out
of the opening there was exactly one
opportunity to win the game outright and
that was that Bishop C7 D6 Motif when
black was essentially out of options um
let's be real if if you're fobby those
are the chances you cannot leave on the
table you know maybe you can leave one
or two of them on the table throughout
the match but not more than that because
you don't know how many of those
concrete winning chances you're going to
get uh from from Hikaru who always seems
to be in good form now other
unconventional opening uh the name that
comes to mind when I see this position
is Richard report the Hungarian grandmas
uh who in earlier stages of his chess
career did exactly this he would play C4
and then he would show up a proclivity
to play H3 and G4 rather than the more
conventional G3 the kind of hyper Fen
ketto yeah you when you said Richard
Rapport you just brought a smile to my
face because we do appreciate his
creativity and the thing is here uh
given that white is not engaging in the
center black really needs to be fast to
break through uh to kind of punish some
of this flank Dynamic so expect D5 or
expect some breakthrough here in the
middle because if you let white get
comfortable and get both Bishops to the
diagonals like get the bishop to B2 as
well there could be you know something
in it for for for white so essentially
just developing connecting your Rooks
and you know breaking through in the
middle that's how you punish flank uh
openings and initiatives white is
white holds some long-term assets you're
right there's the bishop pair White's
position is fundamentally sound but he
lacks queenside development and I can't
believe iaru is actually grabbing that
pawn on E5 the move d4 uh seems to win a
piece but it doesn't the queen can swing
over to the other side Queen to G3 and
there if you play Queen E7 white could
support the Knight with F4 so concretely
the tactics seem to work out for white
here are there any alternatives yes
there are Knight to E4 is an excellent
move which forces Hikaru I think to get
rid of his Bishop yeah cutting the uh
that Bishop there on G2 is important
disturbing the queen that the the sort
of coordination that was there and don't
be surprised at some point there might
be a queen H4 sing for black um
particularly if that pawn uh that black
pawn does land on e4 it'll be hard to
dislodge that Queen it'll be extremely
uncomfortable to ever castle and again
Naka is going to have to justify his
play with this King in the center maybe
going to the Queen side one day but I
love this C5 move cutting the Knight on
A6 C5 is indeed a great move it was
actually the the only move I think
because black was threatening to trap
the Knight with F6 but of course there
is a downside to what hikaru's done he's
given up his uh temporary extra Pawn
Fabiano has captured it and now the
Knight drops back to E3 hitting the
queen exposing pressure on the C5 Knight
and if hikaro Kasa can get in the moves
B3 and Bishop B2 there will be hell to
pay down the dark SES along the long
diagonal I actually don'tlike hikaru's
but he's gone instead and that affs the
extra option of sinking his Knight into
A4 yeah and it's funny that Knight E3
move was also prophylaxis against Knight
D3 check when the queen was on D5
staring down the Rook on H1 there was
some Discovery action as well but uh
we're a bit far removed from that at
this point um okay A5 here I love what
uh what Fab's doing here just trying to
create a mess and and open some files
for you know his Rook essentially this
King on E1 is GNA it's going to be hard
and hard to justif five there's no
initiative on the black king and so Naka
is trying to combine ideas with some
with Knight F5 but they just don't work
right now yeah there's no squares
there's no access points on the king
side his bishop and his knight uh they
look pretty but as long as Knight F5 can
simply be met with Bishop takes F5 uh
you said it white white is out of ideas
on the king side his king is not safe
his position is not stable black is much
better again so Fabby has had clear to
winning advantages in all three of these
first games but this is what makes
Hikaru Hikaru he just holds these
positions with his teeth and he makes it
so hard to make further progress and
there we see a case in point Rook G1 I
think that's a good move he might try to
get his Rook up to G3 and patch up some
of the holes on the king side yeah and
he's trying to justify the the Phantom
pressure on G7 right so there's this
Dynamic of the bishop on B2 looking at
G7 the Knight potentially going F5 and
if the Rook is along the G5 as well he's
just teasing out Knight F5 and it's so
important here for Fabby to keep the
time Advantage because again the
Skirmish is not is going to happen it's
not a matter of if it's a matter of when
and he needs to be ready and he's doing
a great job of that so far currently
both players at about two minutes and 40
seconds uh we are in the first segment
of our second sec match of the day if
you're just joining usar Nakamura takes
on Fabiano Carana in another
scintillating quarterfinal matchup we're
only 30 minutes or so into the match
we've got another hour of five plus one
left to play and and as we've been
discussing this is the segment where
Fabby really has to make a statement and
jump out at top because we know what
Hikaru can do in the lower time control
segments okay Rook back to A7 that Rook
was attacked it's interesting to me Kasa
that Fabby chooses not to take on C he
really believes in this Knight even
though it's on the rim it's still
exerting serious pressure on White's
Queen side I think the other Dynamic at
play is that that it basically can take
it when he feels like and so he's just
feeling the timing is not there yet I
also think you know even though black
has more space in the center and the
queen side there's something resembling
a dark Square grip that would concern me
in a Time scramble because even though
uh you know technically you know the the
bishop on C should Faire reasonably
uh if you just discount the A3 Pawn
there aren't a ton of targets long term
if the Queens came off the board or
something like that so I'm a little bit
concerned about some dark dark Square
grips and maybe even Bishop B4 at the
right moment saying hey you never took
my Bishop I'll actually keep it and
speaking of right moment I think hearo
found a great moment to jump with his
Knight to F5 and finally open up direct
line of fire against the G7 pun Bishop
takes F5 seems absolutely forced I think
Fab just kind of forgot about this move
kind of receded into the into the
background of his mind uh but it's come
at a very unpleasant moment you have to
take now if you're forced to trade on C3
white recaptures with the queen and
that's a flat out double attack that's a
simple plain vanilla double attack white
will be threatening Checkmate and white
will be threatening to pick up that B5
Pawn which I think that's the detail
Fabby might have underestimated the B5
Pawn is hanging if you have to play a
move like G6 here you're also making
more long-term weaknesses on the king
side side and I think after Rook takes
B5 white is probably no longer worse
maybe black is not worse either but with
a minute on his clock I'm starting to
believe in hikaru's position here yeah
and as we basically approach this heavy
piece end game uh that we're getting
into it's going to be so critical for
black to keep the Queens on the board H5
FG and Rook H5 what geometry oh no look
at that idea Rook B5 to H5 and you will
not be able to take it because of the
pin and queen a will be unstoppable will
he CaRu find F takes G6 and Rook H5 I
think he will and F G6 uh for black
lends itself to Queen takes C4 check
which is just unacceptable as well
so yeah yeah all right that's the hold
on you see a car right now being like
hold up hold your horses girl F takes G6
and Rook H5 there we go yeah
yeah Moment of Truth Kasa will he see it
no he oh he sees it he sees it
I don't know it's hard to get a read on
his facial look spray he seemed a little
bit frustrated earlier but maybe he's
just frustrated he didn't win this game
quickly enough now you have to keep the
attack going though I mean you can just
trade the Rooks and then take on C4
they're two all the pawns are
collapsing yeah he's just two pawns up
it's as simple as that and his King
remained on E1 for the entire game and
it's safer than it's ever been there is
a mate threat on A1 but1 yeah King F1
King G2 is a great way to defend
yeah you just uh it's kind of like Tom
Brady you know you just just slide up
out of the pocket you know then deliver
the ball down the field it's uh saw for
20 years yeah you can never quite bring
him
down and there it is King F1 and at this
point it is a matter of technique as
some lazy commentators like to
say hey uh typically you know we just we
just you know let it play itself out
given that it's Blitz I would still say
there's still some work to be done um
there's the potential for four versus
threes if the a pawn drops off but the
problem is Black's King is just a bit
too exposed so uh it's just gonna hard
to imagine any type of real counterplay
here the kf1 is actually extremely snug
it is and there's a lot of work to be
done if I had this with white against
iaru I would probably be playing for a
draw I'd probably be worried that his
his Queen is going to appear on H1 at
some point uh and there's going to be
some lightning attack down the defile
but when Hikaru is handling the white p
pieces uh it's like an experienced
driver going 90 milph down the freeway
you're not worried at all you know he's
got it under control he's also down to
30 seconds on the clock as he drops his
Queen back to C2 so he's got this
pressure on e4 and Fabby really would
want to play F5 but he can't because
he'll drop a third Pawn on G6 oh E3 is a
great move Rook D2 Queen takes E4 gets a
winning endgame fb's got to keep the
Queens on the board
mhm okay but this is actually a longer
more impressive defense than I expected
to be honest uh frankly I thought you
know Nakamura would have been able to
get the Queens off the board by now and
given that that hasn't happened there's
still some life for fabbi so uh that's
basically what it comes down to if white
gets the Queens off it's going to be
very trivial uh if not there's still
going to be work to do to to do queen B2
trying to infiltrate h8 Fabby I think
has to go King G8 but then Rook H4 might
be giving him POS oh he goes the other
way but now the hunt Begins the hunt
begins H4 what a slow move in a tactical
position Queen F6 yeah Queen F6 is is is
definitely going to come at some point
there it is there we go and yeah again
these Queen trades just as soon as it
happens it's a wrap it's a WP he's two
pawns up oh he just forced a pawn end
game and Fabby just we know what that
little Hester met he's lost his second
game in a row doesn't matter what Hikaru
plays A6 H3 a for he always seems to
make it work and that must be an
infuriating sensation for Fabiano it's
so easy to be discouraged but frankly
he's had great positions every time it's
the clock Dynamics and then you know you
know essentially being able to navigate
you know the hustle that you know
Nakamura puts on at some point in the
game that creating that confusion um
just navigating that with enough time in
your clock and I don't love that Fabby
repeats uh this position even though it
was great in the previous game I think
it's good to throw Naka off and here we
are we're almost in something that you
know you could say could resemble a
Kings Indian type of structure except
this Bish buom B7 is really not ideal uh
you know as you well know da being the
Kings Indian guy that you are you
typically want that Bishop on the C H3
diagonal to facilitate breakthroughs
later so for me it's it feels
unrealistic for black to even play for
F5
anymore I mean I'd bet a silver dollar
that we we might see the move Bishop B7
back to C8 at some later point and black
can often afford these kinds of niceties
when the center is closed which is
precisely why Fabby is trying to open up
the queen side he's trying to prevent
Hikaru from getting his kingside pieces
out out and consolidating his position
A4 is a high class move and Knight A2 is
an idea that particularly newer players
should take account of yes the Knight
looks really awkward but Fabby could let
later play the move C3 he could play it
now and kind of break down some of the
queen side and give himself Avenues to
attack so the move C3 can be met with A5
but that would yield uh this lovely
outpost on B5 for the white Bishop so
I'm expecting either C3 uh Fabby might
keep that move in his pocket oh he takes
on pant wow and now it looks more like a
sicilian and now you you gotta like
Black's prospects here because the 92
now is just not great wow so basically
what happened in the last few moves is
basic this 982 needed to justify the
maneuver by going for C3 right away and
now black is able to basically jump on
white in the center before White's
really even ready and
so initiative to Black how many
different openings did we go through
first it it was E4 A6 then it started
looking like a king's Indian then it
started looking like a sicilian nidorf
structure with the pawns on D6 and5 and
now it looks more like a fried liver
than anything else I mean what in which
opening do you hear the moves n 5 D5 e
takes D5 Knight A5 it's a fried lever
but it's a horrible version for white
not just because this Knight on A2 is
bad but Kasa in the fried liver you
always have this check on B5 and because
hearo made the prophylactic move one A6
anticipating that the bishop now has to
drop back to E2 you're able to calmly
recapture on D5 get your Bishop out to
E7 chase the Knight away from G5 white
is much worse yeah I I'll also just to
add to all those points black usually is
a broken Pawn structure on the queen
side and that's also not the case here
either with the A and B pawns being
there instead of your typical A and C
Pawn um so essentially Black's going to
be even in material have a massive lean
development and this bishop on B7 is
just going to be a menace to society uh
this G2 Pawn is just so is going to be
so concerning and even if White Castles
there's going to be massive pressure on
the king side this is not the direction
uh you know Fabby wanted this game to
take but it also goes so this 92 move
was was a little double-edged to the
extent that you had to justify it
quickly if you didn't justify it you
know in a reasonable way it was going to
uh be bad yeah it had to be followed up
by by C3 now it's too too late to play
the you can play the move C3 here but
then you're actually giving up this
massive Square on B3 you might lose
material outright um Fab's got to find a
way to coordinate the rest of his pieces
I mean Bishop E3 maybe but hikaro will
just cast hiar actually decided to take
on D5 with the bishop which is a
completely viable alternative to Knight
takes D5 that Bishop is nicely
centralized it's actually aiming at the
Knight it's aiming at the G2 Pawn as you
put it it is very much a menace to
society and later on hikaro could bring
his Knight back to C6 uh challenge that
D4 square and last thing I'll point out
is that the queen could move out of the
way and a rook could take its place very
easy position to play for black big
central control bad for Fabby that
that's the one da uh moving the queen to
C7 or B6 and then rook d8 and then
you'll see the queen drop back to B7
even potentially and hit G2 again that
one is going to be really annoying and
uh okay allowing uh allowing the yeah
this this Bish B3 move with Tempo I'm
not so sure about um but okay we're in a
we're in a different position right now
but you can see to me a lot of times the
story in the game is going to be the
time advantage and whose Rooks are
connected first and a lot of positions
and you see here uh black has that
opportunity just castling Simply Now the
B4 Pawn is is under pressure here but
you know black white is not getting the
the time advanture Fab is not getting
the time the Comfort comfort and with
the clock that he needs to basically
play these positions once the Skirmish
happens but I love what he's doing here
and he's got a sick tactic he Hikaru has
just missed a crazy tactic I don't know
if Fab's going to see this but let's put
this on an analysis board and then we'll
keep an eye on whether fabbi sees this
the reason the evalar just shut up has
to do with the move Knight takes B4 now
you can count the Defenders and the
attackers and say well this isn't
working because black is protecting the
queen but in this position when the
distance between two pieces that are
defending each other is wide you have to
look for interference tactics and Bishop
B5 is a classic interference move it's a
check if you take the bishop with the
pawn you drop the queen if you take it
with the Rook then there is the intermet
so Queen takes E5 check then white
recaptures the rook and Black's position
is in complete shambles after Queen
takes B5 you could get your Rook to D1
and white actually has a winning attack
and fobby missed it and these are the
chances CA yes I'm saying this from the
comfort of my room I'm not the one
sitting in front of hkar Nakamura
thankfully but let's be real about this
you're not going to get a lot of these
tactical chances and instead he's gone
the other way he's gotten Bishop F3 and
I still think Fab's doing a good job of
producing practice chances but that was
a big right there yeah and again tactics
are often the product of loose pieces or
just a lack of coordination and you know
Naka could have the opportunity to just
Castle connect the Rooks and you know
some of these you know moves on the
queen side were just a little frivolous
and so you know black still maintains an
advantage here uh but you know again
even if you don't see some of the
brilliant tactics that da just spotted
you know a lot of it comes down to just
chess principles and
coordination yeah reality is Hikaru is
still unced you called it he's got some
flimsy pieces over there on the queen
side and like I said I I still think
Fabby is doing a great job of holding
this position together iaro has left
this E5 Pawn off for grabs it can be
captured right now by Fabby but it's
always scary to take pawns like that
against Taro I don't think that black
has anything big in mind I think hear is
just going to trade Knights and maybe
play Rook bd8 and play for longterm
positional compensation he'll try to get
his Bishop to F6 and maybe the other
Rook to E8 so there's no question in my
mind that black Black's position is
still fine but if Fabby Treads carefully
he's also set himself up with the 20
second time Advantage the worst should
be behind him at least
temporarily yeah and a lot of times in
positions like this where you're pawned
down a lot of uh professional players
ask themselves is this a marshal
compensation is this not this does
indeed look like a marshall type of
compensation with the bishop coming to
F6 the N9 2 is such a poor piece
although if Knight C1 Knight B3 happens
in a timely fashion maybe you could
start to say hey I'm a pawn up it
matters but no naka is very quickly
targeting those queenside pawns before
that type of REM maneuvering could even
happen Queen C6 is one of those small
moves that you look at and you say ah
that makes complet total sense but it's
actually a really hard move to see it's
hard to spot that these two pawns were
both unprotected and could be targeted
by uh the same piece but now Queen Tak
A4 is possible but maybe there are some
crazy tactics there with Knight C3 yeah
knight3
possible I think it is possible because
you can't take with the pawn and after
Knight C3 Knight takes C3 BC it's white
who's got the double attack on the
bishop and the punt yet another tactical
opportunity that Fabby has to exploit
here I think if he doesn't find that
move he might be worse yeah 100% this is
a a tactical sequence to equalize let's
just be clear about that um uh longterm
here black has the trumps the A and B
Pawn have the potential to produce an
outside passer on the a file and just
frankly the 982 is passive otherwise and
uh yeah this is a really really critical
juncture we are getting to that moment
where the Skirmish is happening and he's
down on time again this is this going to
be the story through this five plus one
segment okay more tactics Bishop takes
B4 what a move by fa everything is
hanging but I think this does actually
work out uh tactically for Fabby if
Hikaru takes with the bishop then
obviously Fabby will take the Knight
with his Rook but what happens if black
plays Knight takes B4 I think Fabby
wants to play Queen takes E7 and we're
gonna get complete tactical pandemonium
there there's some back rank threats
with Rook d8 hikaru's got only 20
seconds to figure all of this out yeah
and I think he's going to figure it out
uh I think you're going to just have the
series of exchanges that's going to lead
to a heavy piece end game again but
there's not going to be enough uh
material on the board to really really
press it although Queen a C2 that is a
key move I actually did not see I was
looking at Queen takes A2 and this one
now maybe ensures the a pawn gives extra
a pawn does give black an advantage
although this should be holdable you get
the Rook behind the pawn at some point
this uh White Rook would do well to get
to C7 yeah and maybe A7 at some point
and as long as he gets behind the pawn
no problems although Naka is doing a
great job job of not allowing that to
happen yeah he's gotten his Queen behind
the pawn in a classical game this is a
draw there's no doubt about that by the
way that pawn on H5 could have just been
captured that was a free Pawn because
the queen would have protected the D1
square but that's tough geometry to see
with only a couple of seconds remaining
Fabby still up on time he should be able
to hold this I'll put it this way it'll
be an absolute Heartbreaker for him if
hikaro can somehow convert this extra
Pawn on A6 he's trying his best he's
gotten his Rook to F6 he's pressuring
the F2 Pawn Bobby staying afloat for now
I don't like this I feel oh here we go
Queen C2 Queen takes B1 Queen A8 okay
Bobby wins the pawn back it it still
should be a draw here but by all means
do not allow a queen trade that's the
one way to lose this for white is
allowing a queen trade into a lost Pawn
end game yeah and I think important for
the White Queen to stay far away stay
away yeah
okay this king is going to start to
March toward the toward the the black is
going to start to March toward G4 at
some point here we go F5 we go Queen E4
maybe and King G4 you got to be careful
sometimes you can get M it here if you
over press I I think iar is going to win
this one yeah no question because
basically H3 is also going to be a nice
Avenue in and so if there's a this in is
going to be a problem at some point but
look at the way that Fabby held that
Queen D1 check he didn't take the F7
Pawn that would have lost the game but
here comes hearu again King F6 he goes
back to F6 and E6 and there's so many
checks that you have to watch out for
Fabby doing an amazing job right now of
holding this together yeah and again the
time is going to be It's just tough to
hold these types of positions so we're
we're not quite in repetition land just
yet but hold on he was winning he had
Queen F5 there opportunity to trade
Queens he had an opportunity to trade
Queens but I think he's kind of losing
hope in his ability to win this position
and he's going to play F6 and he's going
to reset his attempts here yeah and
again this is where the torture chamber
continues Queen E5 King H6 at some point
G5 might be play at some point although
you don't want to give you more Avenues
toward the black
king okay here we go still still playing
still
going he's gonna try G5 at some point
well first he's gonna bring his King out
again and do the same thing he's done so
many times I I love the way that Fabby
is kind of keeping his the distance
between his King and his Queen last the
king up to F3 and it's a drawn PA Game
Queen E3 is a H3 Queen g king G4 King H3
Queen D7 maybe maybe King G2 but then
there's a check on
B2 and he's still
going opposition theme start to become
very real I think it's a draw now King
F2 Queen
E4 Queen E4 takes takes King F2 King H3
draw he draws by the skin of his teeth
does got him
move oh my gosh and he's going to get to
H1 wow
wow he was briefly winning Casa with a
queen trade which was missed pretty
crazy but the fact remains Hikaru has to
be pretty happy with the way that the
first half of the five plus one segment
uh has gone he has a one-point lead but
given some of the positions that he had
that's got to feel good for
hikaro yeah I I will say though fabbi
has definitely shown his stuff in this
in the segment thus far I mean if he you
know again stays up on the clock is
ready for those skirmishes he's getting
you know the better of these positions
out of the opening because Naka is kind
of punting on the opening I mean he's
playing H3 and uh some of these
frivolous positions and we know he could
play them well so fab is going to have
to take take his chances in the middle
game um and uh see what happens the
score is 2 and 1/2 1 and a/2 yaru
playing all sorts of offbeat openings
with both colors we've seen 1c3 1 H3 1
A6 and he is getting away with it it's
been a fascinating match folks we hope
you're enjoying the second SEC match of
the day between hikaro and Fabiano caroa
we will be back uh in a little bit with
more action from Nakamura Carana here in
the quarterfinals of the speed chest
[Music]
championship
I'm Andrea and I'm Alex and we've been
playing competitive chess since we were
6 years
old we started by focusing on classical
chess but later we fell in love with
playing Blitz and bullet
online chess has been around for more
than 1,000 years but that doesn't mean
that we can't modernize it Financial
systems have been around for even longer
sounds like it's time for an update and
coinbase is doing just that
reenvisioning an entirely new Financial
system that is decentralized and fully
transparent also huge thank you to
coinbase for sponsoring competitive
chess and making events like the SEC
happen go to coinbase.com updatethe
system to learn
more love playing chess variant or just
looking for something new join us for
the variant Community series every two
months we'll be featuring a different
variant in a series of events and
competition
learn a new variant and compete against
other players for prize money or just
play for fun look for Community Arenas
streamer Arenas and Championship events
six weekly Arena tournaments held every
Thursday will be followed by a
championship event with cash prizes
including a $1,000 first place prize the
third and final weekly Arenas will be
streamer Arenas featuring gifted Subs as
prizes win any of these events to
qualify for the championship the
variance Community series kicks off on
September 7th with King of the Hill
we're the first to occupy the center
wins the game but getting checkmated
still loses and join the variant club
today to learn more about upcoming
events how to participate and much much
more see you in the arena on chess.com
[Music]
we're back at the speed chest
Championship presented by coinbase and I
don't really know who that is I think a
glitch by the production team Kasa help
me out here I don't know just the guy
that's just killed it in speed chest
Championship after speed chest
championship and you know his name I
it's hazy I'm getting old the names
aren't as easy to recollect I've got too
many grandkids you know that is hiara
Nakamura as we take a look at his
performances across the board in SEC of
years past he started in 2016 two losses
to Magnus Carlson and it's been all wins
since then he is the five-time SEC
Champion 5 years in a row and the people
he beat in the final last year's final
he won by a point in one of the greatest
online matches Kasa of all time
yeah it was a total Thriller I'm
actually kind of curious what Naka was
eating just now it seemed like he was
like munching on some are those cheese
Doodles because if they are I haven't
had cheese Doodles since the the the mid
2000s I mean that's being wild this is a
really funny scene garana is eating
hikaro is eating Fabby is like doing
360s on his swivel chair this is a
modern modern chess ladies and gentlemen
oh no that might be carrot that might be
a carrot yeah those are cats not cheese
Doodles okay I think Fabby must be
eating something of the popcorn variety
because he just whoa that was violent
not as violent as what's been happening
on the board but that was pretty
violent yeah no question about it so all
right so the these guys are getting back
to it uh they're they're transfixed uh
on the screens now and uh yeah we'll see
how this develops again the Contours of
the match thus far have been pretty
clear uh Naka is going to create a lot
of confusion and Fabby has to navigate
that confusion with more time on his
clock and if he's able to do that he has
a good chance to actually uh really
contend in this segment and contend he
has to because it's all it all goes
downhill when You Face Hikaru and the
clock time decreases man they are really
in sync today they even took a sip of
water at the same time and uh all smiles
it seems by both players we're going to
get started on uh our second half of the
five plus one segment momentarily what
will we see Kasa from hikaro nakamura's
opening laboratory there is our answer
the Andrew Tang variation Knight H3 and
G3 is his next opening experiment okay
and fabbi is responding to this sort of
like a kings's Indian style with the
with the black pieces um what do you
think the best way to punish that 9 H3
is because I'm not convinced this is it
you know at some point if black goes for
this E4 structure uh break the benefit
actually the 9 H3 is it's not going to
be in the way of an eventual eort four
break totally the downside is that the
G4 Square will be really soft and can't
be covered with H3 which will mean that
the E3 Square uh which is really nice
for black in the event that the
structure becomes closed with D4 uh will
be really sensitive and so that's why
knock is keeping the tension and you
called it not a knight on G4 but a
bishop appears on G4 in order to to
induce uh this this kind of awkward
weakening F3 move but the benefit of F3
for white is now the Knight can okay
never mind he does play F4 pretty Brazen
move but I think hikaro has coordinated
his pieces really really well and if you
play Knight G4 here that at this point
is sort of a one move threat white could
respond with Queen E2 or even F5 there
deserved attention instead the bishop
comes back to G4 and I wanted to address
your earlier question Kasa sadly I
actually analyzed uh one Knight H3
because Andrew Tang plays this move a
lot in bullet and definitely the best
way to play against it is not to play C7
C5 you want to play E5 and D5 but you
don't want to play it with C5 at this
point I I almost want to argue that
hikaru's position is totally reasonable
yeah and it's funny because I would have
totally agreed with you I did prefer
Queen E1 I think it's it was really
important to cover the E2 square that so
somehow Bishop E2 and Bishop D3 at some
point might be a little bit annoying I
actually was familiar with this Knight
H3 at least to the extent that C5 was
bad um so it's funny we both took a
Gander at something we probably would
never consider In classical totally and
great call by yasa that there was a
really nice tactical subtlety there I'm
just going to rewind for one second D
takes E4 double exclam because you
couldn't take the bishop because of e
takes D3 forking the queen and the Rook
we don't have to pull up a board I'll go
back to the live board Ju Just wanted to
show uh uh what that was all about it
was also possible by the way since we
have the board up it was also possible
to start with C4 and the engine was
pointing out some crazy ideas is with
Bishop takes H3 uh and Bishop C5 checks
so this was also possible but how can
you f and then King H1 Queen takes D5
and C takes D3 winning a pawn easy stuff
how could Fabby miss that we go back to
the live board just gross just gross
stuff but basically the position on the
board now youve really got to be happy
with black because Whit P are pretty
discombobulated again I he said two
things the the clock situation you know
fb's a little bit down right now but
it's not the end of the world in this
particular moment and Rooks being
connected and right now uh black is much
closer connecting their Rooks than white
is that means that black is going to be
able to jump on white before hopefully
before white consolidates and that's why
black has the advantage here I've been
in this situation so many times against
zukaro where all of your pieces are on
ideal squares you've done you've checked
all of the boxes you've crossed the te's
and dotted the eyes and you're staring
at the position you but you can't find
anything that appeals to you in terms of
actually finishing the game off you're
looking for tactics so fab is probably
calculating moves like Knight takes C4 I
don't think that move works because if
Bishop takes D3 first and then the
Knight on e4 is gonna hang and that's
how you burn so much time against Yar
you just stare at these positions and I
like the way Fab's playing he's opting
for the slower gradual improving moves
and he's not taking too much time but
hikaro is so good at holding these
positions together even when it seems
seems you know like he's completely out
of options like he's driven to the back
few
ranks here's the thing though da to me
there were better improving moves than
B5 again connect those Rooks try and get
a rook to the to d8 I would have
preferred a move like Queen D7 or queen
E7 or queen C7 anything to get those
pieces that aren't playing in the game
I'm not sure what B5 does beyond
defending C4 but I just think there was
there was better there yeah I think I
think he car has chosen a a great
defensive approach here trading on D3
and now offering up the queen trade and
if the Queens are swapped his knight
from D2 is going to make its way to F3
and he's just not going to be worse uh
in that endgame so the obvious move here
I think for most people is a move like
Rook a to d8 trading on Black's own
terms but white could even consider
white could consider taking on D3 white
could also consider the move Knight H3
back to F2 it's patiently awaited its
moment in the Sun and its moment in the
sun might arrive sometime soon no Fab
has gone for the trade yeah I'm a little
bit surprised I would have probably gone
Queen D7 myself and I think a lot of
times when you're trying to decide
whether to trade Queens to trade queens
or not to trade queens that is the
question right I think a lot of times it
comes down to whose King is safer and
Whit's King was weaker in my estimation
in that position and the material was
equal so I would have kept the Queens
on okay now it's up to Hikaru to
complete the sort of consolidation of
his pieces what's what's giving him
pause I think is this idea of Knight F3
The Rook can come into D1 pinning the
bishop that's a really really unpleasant
pin and then black and double on the
defile so maybe Hikaru wants instead to
play on the queen side with the Thematic
move A2 A4 trying to undermine Black's
Pawn chain presumably hikaro or Carana
would respond with A6 and both sides
have to figure out who that additional
tension benefits yeah that tension
probably favors white just slightly
because the Rook on a is so passive that
activating it would be a meaningful uh
step uh the other thing is that you are
less wary of Rook D1 if at any moment
you can play a takes B5 so I think
that's probably the way to go um again
black is not in any trouble here uh it's
and you know Black's also up on the
clock so I do like Fab's situation right
now I would like in the next few moves
though for to get himself an escape
square and figure out how to make a
little bit more inroads particularly
with that A8 Rook which isn't really
doing anything yeah yeah those are great
points definitely given the opportunity
he would want to play H6 or or even
something like like G6 although between
those two moves I would definitely
choose H6 to also control the G5 Square
prevent an eventual Bishop development
okay we see Hikaru trying to untangle
with Knight F3 you called it Rook D1 now
not possible because because of a takes
B5 when The Rook on A8 would end up
undefended instead we see the Knight
planting itself on G4 and reinforcing
Black's control over the E5 Square can
the other Knight make its way to
B3 yeah that's a good question and it's
actually a really nice Outpost for that
Knight I'm extremely surprised with
knight hg1 from Naka but I think he's
trying to evict the Knight G4 H3 so uh
but it's a not it's not a clean
configuration with those uh those
Knights uh kind of Superfluous there
yeah he's trying to evict that Knight
but but the B3 Square hasn't paid its
rent and uh that Knight on C6 is going
to buy in cash it's going over to B3
great move by Fabby and I think the
situation is now dire for hikaro
Nakamura black could even play B Knight
B3 now you don't have to move this
Knight yet and he does just that and now
you got to look for tactics Kasa is
there okay Knight F6 drops the pawn
that's the problem maybe the Knight
could sinking seeth to F2 instead he
sinking seeth to
E3 yeah that's a a nasty Outpost for
that night and uh again black now is is
better on both sides of the board so I I
would consider again trying to get this
Rook on A8 involved um there could be
some type of doubling F4 could even be
sensitive at some juncture there might
be something to Bishop D6 at some point
uh not currently um4 knight4 he's
blundered his Knight he's blundered his
Knight Knight D4 and it's over and you
know why because Knight on3 trapped he's
got a sack in exchange or he's got a
sack a minor piece with Rook A8 that's
how quickly the game turns and the
reason I say he's blundered his Knight
Kasa
is because after Bishop takes D4 C takes
D4 the pawn on e4 covers up the knight's
only two Escape squares and the pawn on
H3 covers its third Escape Square crazy
yeah it's it's it's honestly a bit
tragic it's Shakespearean even I think
yeah again the time difference here
tells the story for me personally
because when he made that decision he
was no longer comfortably ahead on the
clock and again that's where the
mistakes happen and so he's going to
have to do a better job of keeping that
time Advantage healthy and he thought
that Knight on E3 was completely safe
and it looked safe it was defended by a
dark squared bishop and because white
does not possess a dark squared Bishop
he thought that that mechanism that that
defensive construction was watertight
but nothing is ever watertight against
iaro Nakamura the game isn't totally
over Fab is still trying to stir up some
complications with this interesting move
G5 his idea clearly takes G5 Bishop C7
there's actually a really devilish trap
here that I'll play on the board really
quickly F takes G5 Bishop C7 doesn't
look all that dangerous because of Rook
takes E3 but if you keep calculating the
Rooks are aligned and black picks off
the exchange uh with Bishop to F4 so
there is uh quite a bit to think about
here for hiar Nakamura who doesn't touch
that with a 10- foot pole and instead
eliminates the C4 Pawn forcing the
exchange of knights while he's at it
and G5 is a really creative idea but I'm
a little disappointed he went for that
because there were a lot of end games
there if an exchange down where if he
maintained his Pawn structure a healthy
Pawn structure on the king side he would
have had drawing chances and so this one
now with the structure being compromised
the way it is um it's going to be a lot
harder to hold and uh I think Naka is
gonna Nestle his King on F3 at some
point he's gonna go King G2 King F3 he's
going to eventually make inroads on both
the queen side and and the King side and
it's going to be a wrap there's too many
pawns on the board if if there were no
Queen side pawns there would be very
serious drawing chances but as long as
hearo can keep at least two of his pawns
alive I think that given Black's clock
situation this is a virtually
indefensible position we see Hikaru
throwing in that check on G2 driving the
king back to f8 and using his Rooks
activating them to the maximum but you
see something hold on Bishop D4 yeah I
was thinking maybe bishop D4 combination
with or Bishop E3 it's see the more
pawns come off the board the better the
drawing chances are for black so I'm a
little surprised that Naka part with the
a pawn yeah now it's a two on two on the
king side now the a pawn is completely
inconsequential I think that pawn can be
surrounded and captured whenever white
wants it but look at hear Rook G5 and
black is completely paralyzed black is
just there's too many threats here and
he's also dropping a bunch of Pawns on
the king side it's now it's over yeah
and again that G5 move really really did
turn uh the game from a conver the ease
of conversion perspective because when
black had the pawns on F7 uh if black
had the pawns on F7 G6 and H7 on the
light squares complimenting the dark
Square Bishop it would have been much
harder for white to make inroads and so
this this one you know Bobby tried to
solve the defensive problem tactically
and I think that plays in aa's hands but
this is so frustrating just CA to go and
we see again E4 H6 and now a
transposition into a caroon what's so
frustrating about this is how it it all
seems to come down to these individual
moments py playing another sparkling
positional game he outplayed hikaro in
the early middle game he got himself
what looked like a completely risk-free
end game he got that Knight to B3 he did
everything right and then all it takes
is one seemingly small oversight and the
game turns at the drop of a hat it's a
two-point lead for hikaro and the fact
remains in every one of these games Fab
has been at the very least clearly
better that's what makes aaru's lead so
debilitating you you'd almost rather get
crushed in these games so that you
didn't have to regret uh your individual
moves yeah and it's funny here this
kacan position we have I'm getting
shades of Kem Nick Leo in the last game
of their world championship match which
took on a very similar Advanced kacan
structure with G4 and H4 and the reason
that Bishop on uh would drop back to D7
after being attacked was because if the
bishop went to H7 instead and maintained
on that diagonal there's this E6 Pawn
sacrifice which is you know really
adversarial to to deal with over the
board great point and that is indeed the
reason black has solidified his Center
and kept White's pawns at Bay okay so we
see with his last move black is trying
to win back the pawn that has been
hopefully for black temporarily
sacrificed but sometimes permanently
sacrificed Knight D7 and if white wants
he can cling onto the C5 Pawn with this
move B2 B4 you also whatever you do do
not blunder Queen A5 check Kasa I feel
like for newer players this is maybe the
most commonly overlooked Fork the queen
check on A5 even a lot of GMS forget
about that check so many games have been
decided by that fork as we see Carana
defends against Queen A5 but does give
back the C5 Pawn Yeah and the problem
with basically giving the C5 Pawn back
comfortably is that you essentially just
are left with a sea of weaknesses um G4
and H4 are a bit more than overextension
than real tangible attack right now and
the really cool thing is if white
exchanges on C5 and then takes on D7 the
King on D7 is actually quite secure the
Knight can come to E7 you can imagine uh
the Rooks are actually get connected in
you know kind of creative but you know
still legitimate way and again the time
situation one minute up on the clock for
knockout that's gonna matter no his time
management is is absolutely exquisite
he's put so much pressure on the board
and and on the clock in all of these
games and I'm with you I think the worst
uh of Black's problems are are behind
him I think Fabby had this opportunity
to play B2 B4 and that would have been
the principled approach because you'd
almost rather give up the E5 Pawn than
the C5 Pawn but that ship has sailed we
have a completely new pawn structure
Fabby has to complete his development
with Knight F3 but but the reason he's
pausing I think is he's trying to
evaluate uh who Bishop takes E3 benefits
because white would have to capture back
with the F Pawn I actually like that
transformation for white because white
would have had this opportunity to use
the pawn as a battering ram but look at
hikaro inducing a weakness of the F5
square and now he's going to quickly
bring his Knight over to that Outpost
and later on recapture on H5 yeah I
actually thought the whole point with
taking on C5 and playing F4 was to try
and get Rook H3 Rook C3 and try to play
it dynamically there you know bring the
Rook along the third rank that ship is
clearly sailed and basically the Knight
on F5 is so Superior to its counterpart
and that's why black uh you know is
better here although taking on H5 was
not necessary the the pawn H5 was not
very great uh and the Rooks now being
split does give black a little bit of
time sorry give white a little bit of
time to maybe write the ship at least in
the short term long term the structure
is a problem that pawn on H5 though it's
like when you go to a drive-thru and you
know you promise yourself you won't eat
in the car but by the time you get home
you realize that you got no french fries
left and you know half the burger has
been consumed that's you know it's hard
to keep that pawn alive for very long
and you called it CER Rook H3 uh comes a
little bit later perhaps than we
expected but Rook C3 is now a huge
threat it skewers the queen to The Rook
so Hikaru presumably will either move
his queen or move this Rook to Higher
Ground on C6 I like a move like Queen to
B5 keeping the queen in the general
vicinity of the queen side he drops it
back to E7 also solid and I think think
we might see one of those colinear moves
like Rook C6 or Rook C7 because okay he
gives up the C file but now I like the
placement of Fabius Queen I think
hikaru's point is that there are no
infiltration squares down the C file and
The Rook on D1 is kind of a you know
awkwardly place there what is it doing
right it's kind of biting on granite on
D5 yeah I I I must say I do not like The
Rook trade I think every piece trade is
helping black considerably and the pawn
structure on White's Pawn structure on
the king's side is really uh not a sight
for Sor eyes I always like to say with
Pawn structures pawns are kind of like
like kids on a field trip you know they
got to hold hands on the public places
or bad things are going to happen and so
these pawns aren't holding hands F4 is
weak H4 is week this is an ideal long
term that's a great analogy and black
pawns they're kids on a field trip that
are behaving themselves they're holding
hands as they cross the road especially
if black plays the move G6 completing
the as my coach would say completing the
architectural design but beautifying
Black's position to the maximum but
Fabby using some tactics to keep the H4
Pawn uh protected Knight takes H4 there
would have run into the nasty move Rook
H1 so I was half joking about G6 but the
additional benefit of that move is that
it does potentially reinforce the threat
of Knight takes H4 I think the trend of
the game the last couple of moves has
been moving in Fab's Direction he's
found a way to activate his Queen I
think he should activate it further with
Queen A7 and now for the first time in
this middle game he's got concrete
threats against Black's King with uh the
very nasty Prospect of something like
Queen B8 check and queen f8 looming
large yeah and I think now is the time
uh you know to try to activate that Rook
with Rook D3 Rook C3 try to get the rook
in the game longterm you'll also
consider I was going to say A4 A3 just
giving your king LT we saw that in
previous games where fobby held off on
that and now it's just a matter of
getting that rook in and if that Rook
can invade on C3 or B3 the structure
will collapse on the queen side Black's
Pawn structure specifically and maybe
even the King on E8 yeah this is a much
bigger threat than than it seems to be
right because you might think from a
distance ah you know the Rook gets to C3
I move my queen away but no then white
would have infiltrated to B8 and that is
the reason why hikaro has brought more
security to the king side and he's done
it I suppose that is the queen side he's
brought his Knight to C6 covering up the
C file of course he has completely
relinquished uh his hopes and dreams of
ultimately picking off White's pawns or
not as he uses his Rook to fulfill that
obligation what about Rook C3 Casa Rook
takes F4 Knight D4 I think that might
put black on the brink of disaster
vicious tactics to be sure but I
actually do like this Rook F5 move from
a practical perspective because it was
going to take way too long to do
anything else and he misses it he missed
it Fabby misses that opportunity but
that Rook F five was a really really
good prce tactical decision because
otherwise rook and H5 was not
participating I'm going to rewind really
quickly and really quickly show what was
missed exactly Rook to C3 such a hard
move to play because you part ways with
a bunch of your pawns this is the move
that was missed Knight to D4 Rook takes
D4 there's Queen takes D4 and Black's
Queen is undefended white wins in
exchange if black tries to protect the
Knight with King D7 then after the trade
the queen side opens up now white plays
the move for Rook to B3 with the
Unstoppable infiltration of the queen to
A7 and The Rook to either the seventh or
the eighth Rank and of course the fact
that Fabby has played A3 would come in
so handy uh in disarming any potential
check so that was missed we go back to
the live position I still think that
Fabby is at the very least not worse
probably
better no there's still there's still
pressure here that that it's now going
to come down to the Skirmish on the
clock and I think Naka is doing a great
job of making the inroads uh in
difficult Frank so uh really trying to
figure out how to get in here is going
to be key and I would actually throw an
H5 with if I was white throw an H5 maybe
H6 uh could be timely maybe that Knight
on G5 somehow accesses the F6 Square you
got to try we both got really wide-eyed
at the possibility of an outpost on on
F6 yeah you got to be careful though H5
there might be Knight takes E5 um
currently the Knight on G5 speaking of
holding hands uh several different pawns
are holding its hand Queen G4 is a great
move by caruana preparing to drag The
Rook back to the king side and are there
tactics now with Knight takes E6 Rook
takes it wins the game he's got see got
see that one we we have to see this one
Fab let's go he finds it okay what a
move and look at his whole board
awareness using both sides of the board
as his canvas and now the mate threat is
devastating 97 Casa Rook takes E7 Rook
takes E7 and that King on B1 is
extremely secure you can see the value
of the Escape Square being made before
the Skirmish happens there's no chance
to hold this queen end game absolutely
not there's no Perpetual the F Pawn is
completely safely defended the one thing
you want to avoid with white I think is
Queen takes A6 because that gives yaru a
serious fighting chance it will give him
a pass Pawn of his own Fabby has to
avoid getting nervous here I'm always so
nervous everybody's nervous when they're
winning against Hikaru but this is this
is basic Betty I must say I was a little
surprised 5 wasn't played there a moment
ago uh just eliminating the fngg pawns
um but uh alas I mean this is still a
dominant position although A5 A4 might
create some confusion so still work to
be done yeah there's that that common
cliche it's never over till it's over
it's not never over till the score
sheets are signed I try to avoid those
cliches when possible against hear all
of those cliches aren't just true but
they have to be repeated over and over
again I think people knew to chess it's
impossible to understand how resilient
he car is until you see it in action but
a position like this there's only so
much you can do you literally have one
piece left and as long as Fabby can
dodge the check successfully which he's
not doing a great job of thus far he
should be able to to push this Pawn one
square further easier said than done
although this white is zigzagging up the
board I don't do queen F7 oh my God and
he's down to 10 seconds you called it
the clock situation starting to hurt him
now he's got to go back to B5 and back
to A4 and back to B3 oh he tripled
repeated no no that is a huge huge turn
and realized he got away with one but
you know what happens so often uh da is
when you have these positions where
you're clearly winning and you're
dominant a lot of times you you can slip
into passivity and it's happened in my
own classical games where you have a
position that's comfortable and you just
start making all these defensive and
Galactic moves there was no reason for
Fabby to curl into a ball there I think
the moment he curled into a ball was
when he defended the F Pawn with Queen
D4 instead of pressing onward with F5
eliminating the pawns and pressing
forward all those moves Were King A2 B3
it was all so conservative and that's
why Naka hung around you're exactly
right Kasa F5 would have traded that
last pair of Pawns it would have allowed
him to devote his full attention to the
other side of the board and he
accidentally for players who did didn't
understand what happened there when you
repeat a position three times when the
same position appears on the board three
times that is an automatic draw over the
board you actually have to claim the
draw you have to pause the clock and
call a tournament director and say hey
this position was repeated Thrice I'm
claiming a draw online the draw is
claimed automatically that is perhaps
the biggest Heartbreaker of the five
plus one segment that just can't happen
you can't leave points like that on the
table against
diaro wow what a crazy game that was and
what do we have here another crazy game
with one Knight H3 yeah this one took on
the the character of a sort of like a a
knight a ready but with a chorn style
response with this KN on C6 and I'd
expect to see Knight B4 sooner rather
than later for black trying to at least
provoke Rook C1 and then maybe you get
in the C5 break manually because A good
rule of thumb for folks in non E4
opening so D4 C4 is to not put your
knight in front of the C Pawn because
typically the action tends to be on the
CND files although both sides broke that
rule here want to hear a pun that I just
cooked up in the last five seconds what
did what did Richard's mom uh tell him
when they were playing hide and seek R
Rey or not here I come oh my goodness oh
my goodness and of course R's first name
was Richard he was a early 20th century
player and opening analyst one of the
best in the
world again I like the way that this has
unfolded for hiar nakam I'm to pretend I
never said anything that pawn on H4 is
now a long-term weakness Fabby
ironically pushed it to H4 to produce
weaknesses on white side but I think
it's almost had the opposite effect of
strengthening White's kingside Pawn
chain yeah it's it's a funny position
because I think you really have to ask
yourself with black what are you going
to do with your king I think if you go
King side then the pawn is just on H4
can easily be captured and so I think
black actually has to wait a little bit
with their King and clarify the
situation that's why we see Knight D7
here um basically saying I need to
eliminate that dark Square bishop and
you know what else is tilting about this
position we're likely to see after the
trade on E7 Castle's Queen side for
fabbi and and hikaro will very clearly
then start attacking with with the
classic you know B4 and B5 type moves if
you look at the other side of the board
it's very very difficult for black to
pop open the king side because anytime
in the long run that you play the move
F7 F5 white could meet it with G4 G5
actually using that Knight uh as a good
defensive piece to keep the kingside
closed but we're not there yet and he
cares BL one in one
move and he was being a little bit too
clever there that was cheeky man yeah
that was needless uh that was a quite a
French Retreat I say so myself french
Retreat I I was just showing really
quickly on the analysis board what
happens let me show that again Queen
takes D4 for newer players anytime
there's alignment of your king and the
queen they're on the same diagonal you
have to watch out for Pins hey it's not
letting me play Queen takes G7 that's
because that is illegal and white drops
the queen but the game is only beginning
Kaza yeah he lost a pawn in the center
but immediately striking back with E4
and Fabby cannot rest on his Laurels
here and I think that's exactly what
he's doing he's resting on his yeah I
don't know Knight E5 was a bit of a
troubling move because the Knight is
just going to be loose there it's going
to be attacked in short order whether
it's by F4 or Bishop F4 so just not a
great Square for it um but uh Knight G5
is a bit surprising as well because the
Knight on G5 doesn't seem that secure to
me either uh but it's a mess it's a mess
and I think I like the time situation
again I'm GNA keep saying it right now
the time situation is excellent let's
keep it that way but now Knight takes F3
might be a tactic Knight takes F3 and
there's Bishop takes E4 in some versions
but that has to be calculated and I
could envision myself spending you know
25 minutes in a position like this in a
classical game
in the context of a five plus one game
Fabby has to trust his Instinct okay
currently the Knight on D4 is hanging
that's like the only observation that I
can make H3 counterattacking the bishop
and he's trying to deflect the Knight CA
I think your idea Knight takes F3 check
Fab's trying to find the right
opportunity to snap that pawn off the
board and remove the defender of the E4
Knight but this is one of those moves
where the eval to me doesn't tell the
whole story because honestly it's just
kind of a nice move to throw in and
activate that h8 Rook because it didn't
seem like black was going to be keen on
castling King side so even though Naka
is bobbing and weaving right now I still
like the H3 decision I don't know and
maybe I'm being too much of a slave to
the eval bar but you know the problem
here is that after Queen takes D4 Bishop
takes D4 there's also the attack on G7
and it's not entirely clear where this
Knight should go if the Knight jumps
into C4 white can chase it away with B3
and then reestablish no after Bishop
takes G7 white will be a pawn up but
Queen D5 is an amazing move it's a
cinear move Fabby says I'm down for the
queen trade but you're gonna have to do
it on my terms yeah and I think again
now we're finally going to maybe have
that King on E8 evacuate to the queen
side uh uh get those Rooks connected the
bishop pair will be the long-term Trump
I know that's wild to say in a in a a
five minute game but uh you know
there is some long-term potential here
for black and I think Fabby needs to
maintain the clock the time advantage
and he's sinking under he needs next
position too complic what does he do
because right now he car is threatening
to take twice Kasa Castle's Queen side
would have walked into Queen takes A7 he
finds the only way to keep the advantage
Knight C4 is an excellent move Queen
takes D5 Knight takes E3 picks up the
bishop and wins a minor piece so hikaro
will likely drop it back to C1 and the
craziness continues as the Queens are
finally swapped yeah and I think now you
know it's going to be a bit more of a
stal position B5
it's it's it justifies the knight's
position there but it's so radical
reminds me of the G5 move we saw in
another game uh Fabby played where he
just kind of broke out that B Pawn holds
together the constellation of Pawns on
the queen side so you know what I said
about the kids on the field trip I just
don't like it long term but maybe it's
Justified
I think he's just really trying to
establish that clamp on White's position
prevent this Bishop from coming out to
E3 or potentially F4 and obviously the
move B3 has to be seriously evaluated by
Nakamura but I don't think that the pawn
sacrifice on A3 would be justified
because that Knight on A3 would be a lot
safer than it looks it could be
supported by uh the B Pawn now really
quick detour I mentioned cinear moves
several times what is a cinear move uh
people in the chat are asking it's when
two pieces are staring at each other and
you make a move along that file or
diagonal but without capturing the
opposing sides piece so for example if
Black's Rook were on d8 a cinear move
would be Rook d8 to D6 so you're not
taking the Rook on D4 you're moving
somewhere along that file or diagonal
okay hikaro has played B3 Casa what do
you make of that pawn sacrifice are you
with me that are you skeptical about
this yeah I mean Naka is going all in
right now and it's really going to come
down to the next five moves or so if you
know Naka manages to break through his
pieces are extremely active and if you
manag to break through it's going to be
uh it's going to be now if not if Fabby
survives this next juncture he's gonna
have the two Bishops he's going to be up
material and in that sense I'm looking
to trade pieces now so I'd consider move
even like Rook d8 trading my passive
Rook for his active Rook um F5 doesn't
trap my Bishop I could take once and
then put the bishop on H5 and so that's
the direction I would consider that's
such an important point the fact that F5
which looks really scary it makes a lot
of noise but it's largely a paper tiger
e takes F5 opens up the H5 Square for
the bishop but Fabby I'm going to take a
page out of your book look at the clock
he's down to 45 seconds and he
simplifies the game he trades on e4 but
now F5 is I think a much more serious
threat with the pin against the king
maybe you just Castle here yeah I was
going to say that yeah you cast good
excellent timing and I'm going to take
on at 52 and then Play Bishop B2 and F6
is just not going to happen uh and then
I'm going to uh March my a PA A5 A4 and
the bishop accidentally supports an
attack and defense first you have to
protect the B5 pawn and he does Fabby by
the way is handling this end game with
filigree Precision Hikaru is still
trying to stir up complications stir up
some semblance of counterplay but I
don't see anything going for white on
the other side of the board I think
Bishop B2 might win the game yeah and
basically Naka cannot allow a A5 A4 um
but it seems like he is so this should
be his game do not allow Knight E7 Rook
H5 that was an Anastasia's mate now
Hikaru is gonna grab the pawn on B5 Kasa
and I think he's gonna bring his Knight
back and give it give it up for the a
pawn and the game is far from over I
think white does have serious drawing
chances here by setting up some sort of
a fortress and trying to get the pawns
off the board only because it's a Blitz
game otherwise this would the F Pawn if
it remained an F Pawn and that's what
Fab is doing by recapturing the king and
not the pawn it will be enough to win
the game this bishop on B2 is
excellent it is indeed and what's not
excellent White's King on F3 could
potentially get get caught in some sort
of a mating attack if black doubles
Rooks on the first rank black also has
to find a good spot for his bishop and
prevent white from generating
counterplay by doubling on the seventh
rank so there's a lot of moving Parts
here to take care of for Fabby it's an
allout time scramble will he able to win
this with under 20 seconds on his clock
what bothers me just a little bit is you
should be playing moves on Instinct here
because it's essentially a two results
game and so to me these 5-second thinks
are just not worth it and trading a pair
of Rooks here dims Black's attacking
chances I would not go for that I agree
I think this dims Black's chances it
raises uh the influence exerted by
White's connected passers yes they're
currently restrained by Black's Bishop
but it's not enough to restrain them you
also have to go after the G4 Pawn and
Hikaru is starting to stir up serious
counterplay oh my gosh I think this is
in the heading in the direction of a
draw now yeah F five F five yeah yeah
but still now now the G Pawn will be a
factor as well why could lose this yeah
it's a race it's a
race Bishop D4 though picks up the pawn
big move oh Rook takes G7 there we go
and then you hold the pin but can you
trade and go
C5 oh no and he missed it but it's still
going B7 Rook B6 why not Rook G2 check
that was weird to me Rook G2 Rook B2
would have been
faster yep he's got
it all right this is a key game for fbby
to to to hold on to so we're just
waiting with baited breath here trying
and trying now he's got it Bishop E55 F4
consolidates huge win for Fabby there
huge win and really handled the
complications well I mean the bishop B2
A5 A4 sequence job well done the
difference there was he
wasn't lower on time than his than Naka
and the scramble and he left himself
enough to finish off the tricks which we
know will come that's such a confidence
booster because he actually won and
Bishop F5 is not a tilt move that is a
classic Yaro ISM Queen A5 check will
pick this bishop back up black
simplifying the game and kind of
reaching a very very solid scandy caroon
uh type structure but man that's got to
be a conf that's got to feel good
finally Hikaru is punished for his
dubious opening play and it's only a
one-point match you know we've sung
hikaru's Praises in terms of his ability
to defend and ultimately win a lot of
these dubious positions but Fab's level
of play has been very very high yeah it
must be said uh again Fab's a great
player so it's actually not surprising
that he's going to get great positions
well this one with
the this is this is asking for it and
fb's got to win this one frankly he's
got to win this one Castle long I would
say here and get this going get this
show going I have to show a really sexy
Line If instead of E6 if we could blow
up an an yeah I saw this and I'm like
man I got to show I can't pass this up
Queen takes d8 a double attack on A5 and
there's a lot of famous games
that have ended in this way classic
puzzle Rush tactic and the King cannot
escape to B7 or to C7 that would have
resulted in Checkmate and instead we see
E6 from hkar Nakamura forcing the queen
back and opening up a development Square
for the bishop yeah Bish C Bishop F6
yeah interesting position here uh I'm
very surprised I thought black was going
to go F6 and King F7 and try to make it
out that way this one is going to be
excellent if white gets the Rook Rook H1
to E1 uh sometimes even Rook takes E6
might work if that Queen on A6 ever gets
too far and but Casa A3 that's slow very
slow but even King B1 there was no need
to play King B1 that pawn on A2 was
safely defended by the queen I think if
Fabby had simply doubled Rooks on the
defile and infiltrated to D7 he would
have won this game within a couple of
moves why is he wasting time on these
slow prophylactic moves giving hikaro a
chance to activate his own rook and now
Genera
counterplay that is seriously
counterbalancing White's play in the
center yeah puzzling and I think the
thing is you have to understand when
you're you're playing chess whether you
have short-term trumps or long-term
trumps sometimes you can have both but a
lot of whites Advance here lied in the
advantage uh and Lead development and
the safer King and these were short-term
trumps and so those prophylactic moves
didn't Aid in the in the task of you
know kind of Prosecuting the advantage
that white actually had that's why the
eval bar is diminished well said and
it's diminishing even further after this
accurate move by hikara Nakamura Queen
C4
essentially either forcing a queen trade
or I mean my instinct would be to play
Queen takes B7 and allow Queen takes C2
check uh Which is less scary than it
looks because white plays King A1 but in
that position black can then drop back
for example to C6 or to C7 and smoke the
queen out of B7 I think we're going to
get just that Queen C7 there we go and
black has solved all of his problems
yeah the funny thing is if you ask
yourself whose King is actually safer
here I actually would can contend that
it it will be blacks if it's able to
Nestle onto G7 because White's majority
on the queen side is not going to be
convenient to take advantage of with the
King on A1 but that was an excellent
retreating move by Fabby Queen F3 hit
the F6 Pawn forc the king uh to actively
participate in the defense of that pawn
but it's still very safe on E7
surrounded by this Pawn cocoon that's
like a bumper on a car I mean I would
feel very very safe surrounded by my
faithful bodyguards on you know F7 F6
and E6 and important to note that the
reason that Naka didn't play F5 is
because it's so critical that this Rook
on G5 swings along the fifth rank into
the game so you really need to keep the
pawn on F6 until that happens and
surgical Pur case in point Rook gc5
threatening Rook C2 you called it Kasa
White's King is actually far from safe
here yeah and honestly it's it's almost
in that two results range type of game
for me where it's like a win for black
or a draw for black because Black's King
is is quite secure and I can even
anticipate uh black playing A5 here at
some point maybe maybe even A4 putting
the clamps on Black's on White's Queen
side majority it's just going to be
tough to defend he CaRu loves moves like
A7 A5 because they're open-ended moves
and they set up long-term tactical
chances is if you advance this Pawn to
A4 you get the anchor Square for the
queen on B3 so if White's King ever
moves up to A2 there could have been a
check on B3 but hikaro with the
immediate Queen B3 what an Intrepid move
Queen D6 check would have scared a lot
of people away from that move but the
king just drops back to E8 and if white
gives another check on D7 that's not a
Perpetual check black will make his way
to G7 I think Garo is playing this
position for a win yeah and you know
white is starting to have uh you know
you know there's M money more more
problems this is more weak squares more
problems because White's Queen side is
just swiss cheese again those light
squares are weak the king essentially
has back rank
problems it most certainly does Fabby
paying the price essentially the entire
middle game for making those slow moves
King B1 and A3 and I mean he's paying
the price for A3 directly because he
weakened the B3 Square now black is
exploiting it as a stationing point for
his Queen now Rook D5 it should be
pointed out runs into Queen takes D5
black could actually Garner two Rooks
for a queen there with Rook C1 check but
that does not seem particularly
appealing there's that A5 move we talked
about yaru continuing to apply pressure
I'll say this da at any point black can
transition to a rook end game with Queen
takes D1 and Rook C1 check and so I
think basically fixing the white Queens
side majority so important and up here
we go great call it was not the ideal
circum stance to to do it just now I
would say I would say you would have
liked to have made more improving moves
like A4 and H5 and F5 but still black is
not is totally fine I think this game is
likely to end in a draw White's idea is
very clear I mean white wants to play B4
but he wants to do it under the right
circumstances I mean you would love to
cut off Black's King from the queen side
with a move like Rook C3 instead Fabby
brings his King closer to the center
maybe I'm biased by the clock situation
and by the fact that Hikaru is Hikaru
but I feel like Black's position is
still preferable here yeah I'm surprised
that black hasn't played H5 just kind of
fixing the the the G3 Pawn as a as a
backward pawn and a potential Target
later the debate here I think is where
to go A4 or to play a takes B4 I think
that's why Naka is thinking I think
that's exactly what he's contemplating
A4 does fix this weakness on A3 on the
other hand it creates a weakness of
Black's own so you have to calculate uh
you know the King march to B5 in some
situations you know black might even
want to sacrifice that a pawn and try to
get the king closer to the center it's a
very complicated end game probably a
draw objectively but after something
like King D5 the ball is definitely in
White's Court here I think yeah and a
lot of times Rooks behind pawns as
attackers or Defenders are are ideal and
this Rook on G2 this black Rook can go
Rook G1 maybe to Rook B1 get behind the
pawn Rooks that are horizontal positions
aren't usually ideal and that's why I
would say Black's Rook is a little bit
better although that might change
shortly Yaro is going to win a Pawn on
the queen on the king side but it did
come at the cost of his Pawn structure
B5 check a great defensive move
jettisoning the pawn and getting The
Rook over to H5 eliminating one of
Black's pass pawns this is going to be a
draw even without White's H Pawn this
would be at this point a draw he can
choose between Rook F5 and Rook H5 yeah
and if you could choose between going
for uh a rook Pawn or a non Rook Pawn uh
you choose the non Rook Pawn in most
instances because the H Pawn that black
may be left with is really really hard
to Queen and there's always these uh you
know ideas where you're Pawn down it's
it's kind of irrelevant although there's
still a little bit of care here
opposition becomes a theme but King F2
is a threat now F5 would lose the game
because of King F2 and Rook H4 made it's
never too late to lose obviously Fabby
was not born yesterday he gets a well
technically this is a fidor position but
it's a complete moot point with the H
Pawn we're going to see a draw in the
final game of the five plus one segment
Hikaru maintains his lead at one point
Casa yeah very very riveting play I
think it was so important for Fabby to
stabilize the these last few games he
did do that he won a game he needed to
win he held this mission where he really
was in I would say the wrong side of it
the latter half of the game so still
everything to play for into the 3+ one
portion absolutely this has been a close
match It's featured some really really
cool openings and uh wow so much to talk
about so much to play for in the next
segment we'd like to thank our sponsor
coinbase and if by any chance you wish
that your financial systems were as fast
and as smart as the 2023 speed Chess
Championship ship well look no further
than coinbase they can be check out
coinbase.com updatethe system that's
coinbase.com updatethe system check that
out today or use exclaim coinbase in the
chat to learn more well we will learn
more about this match because after a
short break we will get to the three
plus one segment I think we need more of
the same from Bobby he's doing
everything right he needs to be fast he
needs to be good and we will see if he
is up to the challenge here at the speed
Chess Championship presented by coinbase
we'll be right
[Music]
back
we're here in Toronto for the global
Championship I got Fabiana Carana with
me you don't need to talk yet I got
James K we're going to see who
recognizes these guys out of the out of
the random passerbys and we're going to
ask them some fun questions about Chess
for five bucks do you know who this
is no okay actor an actor when you see
this guy any idea who he is somebody
M he is Rob this is actually 50 cents
brother his name is darl Right goes by
75 you want to play chess okay so what
is he a player or something of Chess he
is a chess player I'm not but he is I
play on the side yeah I've been taking
some coaching lessons from Grandmaster
KY over here recently calculation over
everything what's your name again sir uh
my name is jimie what's your name I
already know it it's it's Daniel yeah
Daniel
nitzki okay there it is come on on the
attack baby on the attack if he wins I
know the guys at chess.com we'll get him
a diamond membership okay do you know
what that is yes okay is that something
you want yes yeah okay look at you is
this a London yo we got a pro here with
the London on London how to go I Won Won
that's great hey good game all right I
should have said youtube.com/ csq pod
what is the URL just YouTube actually
don't
remember look at the
[Music]
PO become chessel's next best-selling
author enter the 2023 create your own
course challenge and earn a shot at
$5,000 here's your chance to bring that
course in you to Life share your passion
for chess on an international scale and
Bank while doing it zero course creation
experience no no problem Grandmaster
Maurice Ashley will show you the contest
mechanics then our team will guide you
through the publishing process step by
step like we've done for over 250
authors and best of all the winner will
have their course presented by
Grandmaster Maurice Ashley himself visit
chess.com create to
[Music]
join
the premier online speed chess
tournament a knockout filled with
tension drama quick tactics and shocking
moments oh my gosh for the last s years
in counting the the best Blitz and
bullet players in the world have flocked
to chess.com to prove their worth at
this
format excitement Reigns every year with
major upsets and intense
battles this year 12 invitees and four
qualifiers face off for the title dozens
have tried but only two have ever worn
this Crow Magnus makes it look easy over
he wins the speed chest Championship he
fifth in a row who will be this year's
Blitz King it's time to find
out welcome to the 2023 speed Chess
Championship presented by
[Music]
coinbase okay back we are at the speech
test Championship presented by coinbase
Yar Nakamura takes on Fabiana Carana in
our second match of the day the morning
match featured a scintillating win by
Yan pishi over Arch and aragi to
complete the first round of matchups
currently thear holds a one-point lead
International Master Kasa Corley we've
gotten everything that we could have
asked for in this first 90 minutes yeah
no question it's a tight match um and
this three plus one portion is really
going to tell the story because I think
Fabby has to come out of this with a
slight Le
uh going into the bullet phase so he's
going to have to play even faster and
more deliberately in the segment we've
also seen really interesting opening
choices by hekar Nakamura he's been
doing that quite a bit more recently in
title Tuesdays and bullet braws we've
seen our share of corner pawn moves and
you know Fabby he's done a pretty he's
done a pretty decent job of punishing
hikaro in the opening but he hasn't
capitalized on some of those tactical
opportunities that he had in the early
middle game there was that Heartbreaker
where he lost a knight in the end game
but when all is said and done a
one-point deficit is not a bad place to
be and you want to keep it close if
you're the underdog as we see Hikaru
vibing to imaginary music he seems
confident but so does Fabby Fabby has
been in pretty good spirits Kasa he's
been relaxed he's been relatively fast
and he just needs more where that came
from in the next hour yeah and it's it's
really funny to see Naka bobbing about
because you you just wonder what what's
going on there but I think the
adjustment if there's an adjustment that
uh Fabby ought to make it's that in a
lot of these H6 and A6 positions he's
getting to play uh on the white side of
against Naka that you know Naka is
throwing out there he ought to not trade
as many minor pieces I I see a lot of
positions where he trades multiple pairs
of minor pieces early and then black
tends to stabilize and in a lot a lot of
positions when you have space and you
have this lean development you want to
keep pieces on the board and you want to
keep that confusion on the board because
pieces when you have a lot of minor
pieces or and your lack space it's kind
of like being in a crowded room like the
bo is bad it's hard to move around and
that's really the what's happening when
he gets these games so gota keep some
pieces on the board got to keep some
pieces on the board he keeps his opening
choices from one segment to the other we
will have an hour folks and the time
control transitions to three minutes per
side with a 1 second increment that is
the title Tuesday time control this is a
familiar position another one Knight H3
and this time Fabby changing his
approach a little bit he still drove his
Pawn down to H4 but this time he got
that Kings Indian structure pretty early
on and he initiated it himself by
playing D4 what do you make of this yeah
so both sides have some trumps uh black
has the E5 square and the G5 square and
oh frankly maybe even the H3 was not a
i' consider but now even the H4 square
and so these are really nice inroads for
Black's pieces uh and he's basically
banking on those inroads uh working out
before White's able to Jin up any real
counterplay uh in the center and in the
f file so I like the start here Knight
H4 looks menacing man I I really don't
know why hearo is doing this to himself
but his position is absolutely miserable
and I think there's a very effective
plan here uh that blackhead carry out
and that is to drop the bishop back to
D6 I would start with this move anyway I
don't like Knight takes G2 like he's
releasing the tension and he's doing
what you said he should avoid trading
pieces and playing a little bit too
straightforwardly here although I still
think I still think he's got a big
initiative maybe he's banking on the
Move Queen H4 but it doesn't really
threaten anything Kasa because the H3
and the G4 squares are both protected by
White's Knight and the funny thing about
it is Bishop D6 could have been played
before Knight takes G2 and you would
have had Bishop takes H2 ideas in the
position as well so a little bit of a a
premature releasing of the tension there
although black still is an edge and has
got to try and Jin up some play along
the H file and that's what he's trying
to do he's massing his pieces on the
king side and he carges very calmly just
kind of building a tent on the king side
H3 is a nice defensive move it
solidifies the pawn on G4 and I think
his next move is going to be Knight D2
to F3 when Black's initiative on the
king side well it's already starting to
Peter out and if it Peters out up a Pawn
Yeah do not trade here go Knight G6 keep
those oh maybe Knight G6 runs in the
bishop G5 frankly but you you got to
feel reluctant to continue exchanging
pieces it's not the way well if you are
going to exchange you definitely
shouldn't do it on F3 you should play C5
yeah he does play Knight G6 and we are
likely going to see the bishop uh
deployed to G5 it doesn't trap the queen
I mean the queen has E6 but then you
might also drop the D4 pawn and it feels
like things are starting to get a little
bit out of control here for fobby in in
this first game of
the that's why we reluctantly pulled
back for a moment after KN G6 because
this bishop G5 move is menacing
even I don't know King F1 yeah this is
what I was going to go for the king is
very snug on F1 it's amazing uh most the
entry squares on white side of the board
are actually covered and uh this queen
has to leave the f file and one other
thing I'd add actually this 9 F4 looks
really scary but when you're three
squares horizontally or vertically from
a knight it's actually you're pretty
secure you're totally secure the Knight
has no checks and look at what's
happening now E5 sliced off the
connection between the bishop and the
Knight Fabby had to drop his Knight back
to E6 that was the only move to
Counterattack the bishop he's blundered
this response Queen to E1 pinning the
bishop with the queen and if Fabby now
goes F6 hikaro would have still captured
on E5 and won a bunch of material
instead Fabby jettison the bishop but
he's got very little to show for it I
think after Queen takes E5 he probably
wants F6 there but the queen could even
drop back and take D4 and hit the
bishop yeah this one is not gone uh the
way Fabby would have liked it to thus
far and the time tells the story again
um this segment he's got to be a faster
and more principled and so this one nak
is just trying to figure out you know
which way he wants to win because there
are many roads to roome here yeah Knight
takes e and Knight takes D7 also works
there's a really cool line actually
which chicaro is carrying out Knight
takes D7 Knight E4 and the point is that
Queen D5 which would otherwise trap the
Knight runs into Knight D to F6 check
look at the way that hikaru's Knights
are cooperating Black's got all of his
pieces on good squares and yet there is
no way no easy way for Fabby to continue
his initiative I think that he's going
to lose this once the night evacuates
back to C5 yeah and again like you said
the business squares are covered and
it's funny a lot of times when you're
considering inroads and counterplay for
your opponent just look at the squares
on your side of the board like if you're
white one to four you're black 5 to
eight and consider how many of those
squares on your side of the board aren't
covered and if you consider White's
position almost every Square uh from A1
to H1 and A4 to H4 almost every square
is covered so it makes it hard to get in
there and they're covered because of the
placement of this Knight on e4 it's a
monster Knight on an outpost it's
secured by the G Pawn black can never
play F5 and at this point there's just
no compensation for the piece I think
the only chance for black is to try to
smash through with B5 and Knight E3
check but even if you're able to deliver
that check first of all white can par a
rook on E1 and just sack The Exchange on
E3 which is very hikaro esque but even
if you just move your king away which is
what he's done big deal the Knight lands
on E3 so what but fby grabbing some
pawns on the queen side still fighting
yeah and I did I did like this uh Queen
C6 move sneakily threatening Rook takes
E4 and then Queen takes E4 checks that's
why Naka went for King G1 just getting
out of losing those the two nights for
The Rook there would have given Fabby a
chance now a piece up the pawns and the
queen side are just simply irrelevant
with this extra piece here okay but wait
a second Queen F2 rookie five Fab sing
up complications and I don't think the
queen trade is in White's favor I think
the queen trade is squarely in Black's
favor because now these pass pawns start
to influence the course of the game he's
taking another Pawn on D3 Hikaru is
trying to flag him but Fabby now has
some chances here I still think with
seven seconds in the long run he's going
to lose but he's doing a great job of
staying afloat Knight C5 another great
move and he's plunder G5 with check all
right hold on the game is quite last few
seconds now it's but again the time
situation will come up rook G2 Knight at
five it's going to be tricky I mean I'm
really impressed with Fab's speed and
accuracy right now he hasn't made a
single blund or big mistake in the last
15 moves of course he has to avoid
missing a fork and H5 is going to be
nasty H5 is really nasty is gonna win
yeah F5 Knight E5 Rook takes H6 oh yeah
that's a problem and he might defend
this one he might defend it but look at
hikaru's pieces storm clouds are
gathering over blackes he blundered a
fork
all right we all need to take a deep
breath you know we do especially F in
and out and uh yeah again the skirmishes
or what it's going to come down to but
man that was good defending for such a
long time gosh this match has been so
debilitating for Fabby I mean he was
literally one move away there but Rook e
four such a tempting move get the Rooks
off the board looks like you're out of
the woods and that last retreating night
move that's what sealed the deal wow
Fab's switching it up a little bit in
ter terms of the development scheme he
went for this weird Knight F3 E3 and
then he decided to take the center I
think those those moves essentially are
helping kna build a little bit more than
he would be able to otherwise these are
much better than those Owen style
positions he was getting before this is
a very very dangerous uh point in the
match because you just lost a Ultra
tilting game where not only were you
much better out of the opening but then
you went all the way back from a piece
down position were on the cusp of
scoring the draw and then lost it's so
easy to just tilt another game away
pretty quickly and the way that this
game is going so far I'm getting a
little bit worried that we're starting
to follow that narrative Fabby trying to
stir things up on the queen side Hikaru
his intentions are very clear I think he
wants to play G4 blast open the H file
and Checkmate white on the king side
yeah and this bishop on E5 is just so
unassailable right now it's such a
monsterpiece the couple with the Knight
on G6 as well while getting in on the
ACT it's just really dangerous and
essentially the funny thing is when you
play against these like double fien
shadow type of systems you always a
shutting down one of the Bishops if you
advance in the middle and I feel like he
shut down the wrong Bishop here because
he gave up that massive Outpost the King
has to evacuate the king F1 King E2
might be in the agenda sooner rather
than later oh for sure I mean given
what's going on in the H file first of
all I think Fabby has to take on G4 not
so much to win a pawn but rather to
prevent Queen H4 um of course black can
play Rook H4 but but then that square is
is hogged by uh a piece that doesn't
really want to be on that square in the
first place the queen could drop back to
F3 Fabby will probably play Knight D4
and I think hearo wants to respond by
moving his Queen up to F6 remember black
can also Castle Queen side here and that
will spell a lot of trouble if black can
get his King to safety and connect his
Rooks then Rook H4 and Rook h8 will
become a massive threat
yeah even if you just imagine The Rook
on A8 uh even landing on G8 I mean it's
just it's just just terminal I mean
frankly it's it just becomes such a
tragic uh position to to play because
the king is just in Mortal danger and
you know Rook H4 is a bit surprising
actually
because this might actually help black
consolidate is there some Knight E6
Dynamic no the queen will just drop back
okay so he drops back to D1 we were sort
of okay at least I was insinuating that
Queen F3 is the natural move maybe there
was a bishop H2 check Knight
eure that that gave Fabby a little bit
of fear there because he's brought his
Queen back to D1 I think black should
definitely seize the opportunity and get
his own lady up to F6 maybe potentially
back to h8 so we'll likely see Queen F6
Knight F3 and then the Rook can just
move back to H5 and queen h8 is going to
be a big problem there for white yeah
and I'll just add to that I wouldn't be
total whoa he so he's going to take and
play E5 that's an maybe another way to
handle this no okay Queen G5 what I was
gonna say before this Skirmish was I I
wouldn't I I wouldn't be totally
surprised if you know Naka doesn't
Castle just plays King E7 or King D7 to
bring the Rook into the game also uh it
would it's you know kind of a a fancier
way to do it but could also be pretty
effective totally I mean the King on D7
would be completely safe he's got this
Pawn cocoon that would surround the king
I totally agree I think there isn't much
of a difference between castling and
playing King D7 now if white plays Rook
H1 then I think maybe your best advice
to Castle here um and get the king
further away from the center because D
Tak C6 could be possible of course now D
Tak C6 is I think suicidal opening up
Black's Bishop FAO doing a pretty good
job thus far of keeping the king side
stable maybe he should consider a slower
move like Queen to D2 or you know even
something like B4 and C5 but he tries to
evacuate his King from the will that
backfire yeah why giving up the pawn on
B2 that's interesting Pawn is a
pawn I'm also surprised that black seed
the H file like it was the
transformation was quite helpful um you
know a little while ago we had a rook on
h8 now it went from H4 to H7 to
G7
okay and Rook back to G8 now taking the
sting out of the move Bishop D4 which
was a huge threat that would have forked
the rook and the queen now the Queen is
pretty safe on A3 it's got tons of
retreating squares it can't be trapped
feels like the kind of position that
hikaro really excels in when both sides
are low on time very irrational hard to
get a handle on what's going on here as
Fabby he says two can attack on the king
side you're not the only one who can
have fun on that side of the board yeah
and I'm wary of F5 coming at some moment
to be just breaking down the the the
central structure for white because that
Bishop on B7 if it ever asserts itself
it's going to be a
problem
absolutely Queen
D2 Rook f8 all right feels slow but
teeing up F5 but it feels a little slow
yeah teeing up some sort of E5 and F5
combination maybe I think he should
start with E5 regardless instead he
evacuates his Queen to A4 yeah basically
trying to just get it dart back to D7
just in
case Now Pawn takes E6 and Bishop takes
B6 has to be considered oh no question
and then yeah then Rook takes B7 even at
some point yeah that is extremely
dangerous actually uh
wow and he's done it and hearo
immediately responds with Bishop takes
E4 but now just e takes F7 Now The Rook
on G8 is trapped the Smoke Clears and
Bishop takes B6 ends it Bishop takes D6
devast you got to see this one and queen
takes D6 all right Rook takes C7 oh
Queen B2 even more precise Discovery
Galore and yeah this is this is it he's
taking everything Bishop takes D6 take
another
one I would go Rook takes B7 in a
heartbeat absolutely Rook B7 was best
and here we go again he car still in the
game another sloppy move and now the
game continues oh no no Bishop D no no
no no now I think it's going to be a
draw why you going to opposite color
Bishops Fabby has done this tooo many
times he panics in these low time
situations Rook takes B7 is a move that
he would play against anybody not named
hiar nakam morasa that was an automatic
exchange sack that was mate Seven Ways
to Sunday and now it's actually a three
res game oh my goodness and yeah I would
take black here it's crazy how did that
happen so quickly and play for a
win white has to Asser assert himself at
the G pawn and he's checking the the
king toward the the the the king side
which is where the pawns need to advance
that one I don't agree with either
although maybe there's some
opportunities G5 yes oh F4 there would
have been a big big
opportunity I would have gone F4 even a
moment ago bring the king in the line of
fire The Rook on G4 is puzzling and now
it's D4 is a precise
equalizer and after this game concludes
which and it's going to conclude
momentarily this is obviously a dead
draw it's a blockade I'm going to rewind
and as the next game gets underway I'm
going to show exactly where the easiest
winning opportunity was missed why are
we being so critical of Fab's play
understandable in the sense that he was
very low on time but the moves that he's
missing aren't hard to calculate they're
moves that he would play I think he's
just getting nervous he knows who he's
up against and he's psyching himself out
uh in some of these time pressure
situations and it doesn't bode well for
the 30 minutes of bullet that he's going
going to have to play yeah and we're
seeing Naka already Flex uh some of the
the strategy in these matches which is
to run out clock if you have an
advantage particularly when you know the
faster segments are even more
adversarial for your opponent so yeah he
has to make an inroad here Fabby does
and Rook takes B7 was such a huge
opportunity in the last game just to
shut things down immediately but it's
again when you're the aggressor and you
have a a winning position Remain the
aggressor because as soon as you curl up
into a ball and try that that
consolidation that's when the game turns
let's bring up an analysis board really
quickly as this one gets underway we
have another one night H3 another ugly
looking position for uh for Hikaru
Nakamura but I'm going to rewind all the
way back uh to where that opportunity
was missed after Exquisite tactical play
by Fabby all he had to do in this
position take that Bishop get rid of the
final Defender drop your Bishop to E3
and hikaro would have have resigned
because King A8 Bishop F3 is Checkmate
in a couple and if you go the other way
if you go to C7 you've got Queen B6 and
the simplest way to win you can play
Bishop G4 you could play Queen to B7
check Rook C7 and Bishop G4 but these
are Elementary moves that fobby would
have seen in a heartbeat that was the
cleanest win Kaa once he missed that he
also traded the bishop for the Knight
and after that black was no longer worse
crazy as we go back to our current
position and our current position is
again going into the toilet for Fabby
yeah the double G pawns do are not a
cipher Sor eyes and essentially that
King on G8 may be a little bit weak
although I I do like the C6 move
practically covering the D5 Square
trying to sh things up in that diagonal
and I think B3 is just a bit slow
because it uh you you could have
probably you know made some quicker
inroads but black starting to maybe you
know get out of the wor the worst might
be over by
now okay but I just can't believe the
kinds of positions hearu is getting out
of the openings that he's playing one
Knight H3 I never knew that gave a
better position out of the opening okay
C5 keeping the center closed yeah I I
think now you forfeited the long-term
trumps I would have probably gone for
Queen
F6 Bishop D6 something along Knight E5
that combination of moves I think is a
little more sensible White's going to go
Knight E4 uh Queen D2 Rook F1 and it's G
to you know punch through eventually
okay Queen C2 is also a completely
reable move you hit the Knight I would
take that Knight and maybe play
something calm like Rook A1 to
E1 I mean Black's got terrible Bishops
instead car inviting a queen trade and
the reason I say that is because Queen
F6 here which probably is the only move
because Bishop E4 is is a massive
massive tactical threat that end game
though is so miserable for black he's
got terrible pawns he's got bad Bishops
and I think Fabby trying to find some
alternative to swapping the ladies but
there's no choice you have to bite the
bullet here yeah and then he's gonna
have to hope that his two Bishops can
fight uh reasonably against the
protected pass on D5 but the problem is
is that Bishop on C8 in particular is
really really limited and white will
have all sorts of uh strategies with
planning the bishop on F5 at some point
to just trade uh the bishop pair another
lwh hanging fruit type of idea get this
King Park it on F3 where it solidifies
all of your important pieces and Pawns
in the center he's done just that don't
go Knight D3 there's always to Wonder
Maybe H3 first just to secure that pawn
even further uh should be thrown
in yeah he's doing all all the
consolidating moves uh Knight D3 will
probably happen sooner rather than later
and uh yeah uh White's gonna White's
gonna maintain an edge although Bishop
F5 is a really nice move just trading
everything that move displays such a
keen understanding of of endgame play
because after the trade Black's position
is completely hopeless in fact Black's
Position will be hopeless even if you
drop the bishop back to E8 because
you're just going to drop the F Pawn
you're going to drop the c Pawn Black's
position just completely crumbles
without the presence without the
defensive presence of a rook also just
d67 promotes the block yeah yeah Knight
E4 it lifts the blockade and then the D
Pawn marches down the yellow brick road
and that's that's that's how it goes D6
D6 D7 and although technically okay
technically D6 Bishop C6 is possible but
after D7 Bishop E7 I think white can
just snap that pawn off on C5 and then
A6 also falls even if white doesn't
promote immediately Black's dropping all
of his pawns even just starting with
King F3 the bishop on f8 now is such a
passive participant so you really can
you know you know you know take wind of
you know check the weather you know just
just you know do all types of things and
uh then come back to it later he's gone
for D6 that's the concrete that's the
most straightforward
approach and uh looks like Fab's days
here are are
numbered maybe maybe he's going to just
play night takes C5 at the end of it D7
after Bishop C6 D7 Bishop E7 Knight
takes C5 and go that route um and yeah
you know what's a lovely lovely winning
idea here is to go Bishop E6 check and
then move the bishop back to D5 the
black Bishop is cornered has to go for
the trade and with only one Bishop on
the board Black's black runs out of
options because the Knight is going to
replace the bishop on E6 Fabby might
resign after Bishop D5 yeah I was
surprised uh Fabby didn't uh play F3
check as an intermediate move after
Knight C5 just a little toss in there
but here we are I think this is the
right choice E4 D4 Knight C3 I think
this is the way to play against this
really dubious Owen setup and just don't
trade pieces Fabby that's what I want to
see he's done this once before uh he's
he's tried a variety of different setups
in the first game hikaro pushed an early
C5 and allowed that boniik structure
obviously Nakamura didn't like what he
got there and instead he plays the more
the more hippo is type of structure I
think we're following that game where
Fabby played A4 and Knight A2 now I like
A4 and Knight A2 here as long as you
follow up with a rapid C3 and I'm
curious to see how Fabby improves upon
his earlier play yeah 100% And he he he
goes for it now although practically
speaking it's still not the easiest
position to to prosecute because black
does get the C5 Square for the time
being although Bishop E3 takes it away
Knight G4 I'd expect here no okay um I
would hassle that Bishop on E3 if I
could manage to um and now I think this
is actually pretty close to the ideal
setup for white in this position white
will be able to park a knight on B5 at
some juncture later in the game F5 break
is not really on the cards and it's
really this bishop on B7 and and C7 and
a A5 pawns that are potentially
weaknesses long term yeah this is like a
king's Indian but it's inferior in five
or six different ways you know the
bishop on e7's worse than on G7 okay now
it's a completely it's a more Sicilian
structure uh as it was in the previous
game hikaro played C6 there he plays it
here now he's saddled with a weakness on
D6 is there Knight A7 Knight A7 wins the
game oh yeah that's that's also EXT
that's sick move yeah I I was looking at
Rook takes C6 that
also but oh it doesn't I don't think so
I don't think so because I think after
you trade black has the intermetzo
Knight C5 and it's so important to get
that Knight to an active Square I need
to show Kasa what was just missed it was
the move Knight to A7 in this position
I'll let you explain it Knight A7 why
does this end the game oh it's just a
excellent excellent Fork of the bishop
on C6 and The Rook on C8 and really
nothing nothing changes after Queen
takes B3 uh Knight takes B3 if Rook
takes A7 as you were about to
demonstrate there you just have Queen
takes B8 first and then the Rook on A7
is hanging and that's an exchange with
some interest because there's still PRS
long as cile well explained this would
have ended the game and this is exactly
what we started our broadcast by
mentioning when you get these one move
tactical opportunities against Saro and
you don't exploit them your chances
dwindle to almost zero now not to
overstate the case the position remains
very complicated Fab's got compensation
for the exchange he's got a monster
Knight he's got a pass Pawn on D5 but
all of that is essentially a mood point
because of what was available and what
could have led to a very important
victory that would have brought hekar
lead down to two now if anybody's better
I think it's probably black I feel like
black has this very very impressive
blockade on the D6 Square yeah no
question about it and I think it's
really instructive for folks at home
this G3 and G6 both sides making the
Escape Square uh basically to play
against their opponent's Bishop so uh
White makes the escap score on G2
because black is a dark squore bishop
and black does the same on G7 because
white has a light squar bishop and so
both kings are fairly secure and it's
really a question if who's going to make
inroads black is is actually has an
excellent blockade on the D6 square and
now can probably press against F2 with
Bishop C5 Rook F6 at some point it's
going to be tough The Rook can also dive
into C2 attacking B2 and potentially F2
Fab's best best chance I think is to try
to push D6 at the right moment it's
still not possible black has one two
three Defenders on that square and only
two
attackers and Rook C2 Rook C2 Rook C2
looks terrifying for white because it
threatens Bishop C5 and the dark squares
the dark squares are killing Fabby here
but Hikaru playing it slowly with King
G7 he's kind of maintaining the status
quo and trying to milk White's clock
down to below 30 seconds before taking
any decisive action I think and honestly
I would actually consider Rook C1 it's
probably a really wild decision to trade
when you're you know down material but
this Rook C2 infiltration I I need to
stop it somehow and I also I'm really
worried about Bishop C5 and he's played
it and I agree I think Rook C1 which
he's played apparently he's played it at
the wrong moment I don't know
why oh my gosh there's a crazy tactic
here but it's so to spot E4 and Bishop
takes F2 Queen takes G3 hikaro by his
facial expressions you can sense that he
knows there's
something will he find
E4 yeah it it felt just a little bit
loose Now The Rook on C1 unprotected and
when you have unprotected pieces tactics
just start to happen so that's why
rookie won a moment little bit earlier
was a little bit better choice so and
man lots of mistakes Happening Here Rook
C6 would have been better for Fabby let
me show this really quickly this was a
beautiful tactic I think hearu is going
to win the game anyway but E4 and Bishop
takes F2 was the immediate win because
the Rook is hanging and if you take on
C8 then Queen takes G3 and Rook takes F3
obviously leads to a devastating attack
against whes King so that was uh a more
immediate win for hikaro and steady
dropped his Bishop back to B6 here Fabby
had this opportunity to play Rook C6 and
establish a much more powerful passed
one on C6 instead he acquiesced to the
trade and once again I'm pretty sure
that hikaro has a technically winning
position yeah so what chances are there
for white in this position well the
chances lie in hopefully white being
able to get rid of this dark squared
Bishop maybe for that Knight securing
the getting the E Pawn as well and then
all of a sudden with the D Pawn uh even
being an exchange down there are really
good chances to hold but it's hard to
imagine all that happening um in a span
of 20 seconds here for Fab's clock it's
ticking it's ticking and hikaro is
loading up the tactics along the f file
there's that E4 move and he's played it
at a great time E4 hitting the bishop
and Engineering a favorable trade for
black he's going to pick off this D6 pun
I think he's going to do it by playing
Queen to D5 to pin the Knight Exquisite
Precision here by Hikaru Nakamura and he
is just technically winning in this
position yeah and it's it's just a huge
problem because now he's going to Rook
takes D6 and then just bring the Rook
back to F6 even uh and there's just a
lot of pressure here the extra Pawn on
the queen side just not relevant right
now Fabby trying to trade off that a Aon
so that he can devote his full attention
to defending the Knight but it just
seems like it's a matter of time four
seconds for Fabby I think hikaro needs
to go after that a pawn and he might do
that by playing Rook to A5 yeah there it
is and now you can even look to trade
Queens um it's not strictly necessary
but uh even with the three three on
three on the same side it's going to be
enough there were no other moves white
was in zuk song there was no way to
maintain a defense of the Knight and the
lead is starting to
balloon yeah and there's still time in
the segment to get it back but he has to
start with one game one game at a time
you're getting positions where you're
better and you just got to maintain that
edge easier said than done da much
easier said than done he did everything
right if he had found Knight A7 this
match would have felt a lot different as
it stands yukar wins the game you know
these openings are wildly successful for
him Fabby keeps changing his approach
against Knight H3 and I've liked every
position that he's gotten with black the
problem has absolutely not been in the
opening but can he close his eyes and
just push that H Pawn up the board and
run white over along that
file this is an interesting choice
giving up the the bishop pair but trying
trying to potentially get an
H4 um very double-edged very
double-edged position here what is searo
gonna recapture with yeah I would
actually say he's probably gonna
recapture with the Knight oh that was
the wrong third option yeah is he gonna
recapture
no all
right H4 what do we make of this totally
natural move I don't know if I'd call
this a mistake King G2 I would would be
my first
instinct my instinct would be to play G4
to be honest like my my my snap instinct
is to keep the king site closed but
apparently that's not the
best yeah it's uh I'm curious to what
Naka is going to go for here but uh I'm
just I don't want to In Tune my bishop
and I I think if I play King G2 it still
prevents black from castling
along whoa he's taken but what about H
takes G3 with a discovered attack on the
bishop what is he intending
here I have no idea King G2 now but he
could have thrown it in before it's just
strange but yeah King G2 is probably
still legit and then rookie one I
actually like White's position Kasa and
the reason why is that black can't
Castle Queens side that's illegal
because of that pesky Bishop now there
must there there tactics down the E file
I think you can started with Rook a E1
but yeah F4 is super super nasty yeah
yeah I think now black has maybe some
chance to consolidate but what how do
you do it is it Knight G6 no then the
queen just moves away how do you
consolidate um Rook H5 there is F4 that
doesn't seem to work
either do you toss an H1 Queen do you
toss toss an H1 Queen in one of these
variations and I don't see how have the
Rook being on H1 makes a huge difference
but there's something here in some
situations a rook on H1 could actually
hurt you because of the X-ray and the
potential for some sort of a bishop D7
check related
Discovery but your point is well taken
Queen G5 check but that runs into Queen
G4 and that is the Crux of hearu play
Queen G4 forces the Queens off the board
and When the Smoke Clears I feel like
black is going to lose this Knight on
E5 yeah and again really really tough
position here practically speaking with
the kingst on E8 and it's again why he
didn't uh Clos that diagonal down but
yeah Queen G4 is a is I think will be
found King H1 is because it drops the
bishop Bishop G4 is very tempting but
apparently there's this brilliant move
F5 and Fabby missed it he's played F6
which is the next best thing but Queen
G4 would have forced the Queens off the
board and would have allowed white to
play F4 now F4 is impossible because you
dropped the bishop on G4 that gives
Fabby the tempo that he needs to move
his King away from the danger zone and
practically speaking here I I I know
that Fabby has some some pawns to work
with but practically speaking here I
think it might be easier to play White
the light squares around Black's King
particularly E6 G6 F7 H7 swiss cheese
and there's a lot of potential ways to
get in there and he starts with F4 I
would have probably moved the bishop
first and then tried to go F4 but he's
going for exchange and I think the queen
trade will ensure that Fabby
escapes I agree and it looks like we
will see a mass Liquidation on F6 we're
going to get a double Rook end game and
H is going to end up winning the H2 Pawn
so a draw is now very very
likely
yeah all right I don't know why he's
thinking here I would Bishop B7 to me
would be automatic yeah Rook E8 is
actually a terrible blunder here because
of e takes F6 maybe he was
double-checking that line a little bit
scary for black actually Rook G4 check
is a major
threat oh my goodness yeah rookie 72
wait a second this is suddenly wait Rie
G4 is made in two because if Rook takes
H2 M there is a m threat here and the
scary part of it is this H2 Pawn is just
a shield it's white is gonna secure that
pawn basically whenever he wants so he
does not have to to work on it just yet
H how is this possible how is Fabby the
one who has to defend in this position
and he's all low rookie seven check and
then Rook takes then Rook F7 and Rook
takes B7 and it's maybe even lost for
black now I think the the Salvation
might be in that the King gets to enter
uh to the queen side faster than you
know white does so I would say maybe
some some activation here King F5 or
rookie eight as you're demonstrating but
this is critical the fact that it you
know it's black who who has to fight for
the draw here is is just absurd and I
love the move Rook d8 I think that's a
very heads up move by Fabby he's he's a
pawn down here so he's G to get tortured
but this should be a saveable position
he's got his his King is on an optimal
Square his Rook is active I don't think
hearo has enough pawns uh to to to
produce serious winning chances here
he's going to try and he's going to milk
some time off the match clock but this
should be a handily savable with 30
seconds on the clock and the great
frustration of positions like this when
you are defending a pawn down uh Rook
end game is when your defend when the
pawn with what you're defending Pawn
your sole Pawn is not on the same file
is one of the opponent's two pawns
because it means that there's sometimes
additional
levers and iaro will milk every last
chance in this end game he will try
every last trick and keep Fabby on his
toes white black needs to avoid getting
impatient one way to get impatient would
be a premature C5 which would allow
white to establish connected passers
with B5 he's played C5 in the right
version though and now we're heading
toward a imminent imminent draw yeah and
this is uh for the folks at home this is
uh getting closer and closer toward a
filor position which is the drawing
version of these Rook end games so you
see The Rook on the sixth rank holding
the line not allowing the king to cross
into the to the sixth Rank and and
create mating threats and so the only
way white can improve is by actually
getting the B Pawn further and then
pushing it to the sixth Rank and as soon
as that happens the black Rook comes
from behind and starts the Perpetual
checks very well explained the filor
position of course named after Andre
fidor arguably the greatest player of
the 18th century and the AU auth of one
of the first fulllength uh instructional
manuals uh on chess which is actually a
pretty high quality book it has a lot of
opening analysis uh it has just general
maxims for the chess player and it's got
a it obviously has an analysis of the
endgame uh he he coined and he he he
discovered a lot of the positions that
we now take for granted but obviously we
know what hiar is doing right it's not a
surprise to anybody he's milking the
maximum amount of time and Kasa he can
potentially milk something like three or
four minutes off the clock because he
can play this forever yeah the B Pawn is
can be pushed as well and then the 50
move rule counter resets and so he can
entertain this for at least another I
don't know two three minutes or
something and knowing iaru he will know
exactly when the 50 move R is about to
be reached and then he'll push B5 do it
again for 50 moves and then push B6 and
do it again for 50 moves then give up
the pawn and do it again for 50 moves so
I mean there is a limit to it and I
don't think this is necessary but I also
can't really blame him for doing this
what do you think the longest game in
SEC uh history is because there's
potential here frankly oh totally like
if if they could easily play another 100
moves here I don't think that's going to
happen maybe it will I wonder if the 200
move game has ever been reached in SEC
history I'm sure it has my goodness this
is uh just add it kind of adds insult
injury but it is the proper strategy um
and so you know it's uh and then and
then at the last moment he'll kind of
troll and go for a move like Rook C6
just to make sure there isn't just
pre-moving going on on Fab's end yeah
obviously you're also testing fabbi on
his Mouse skills if you're Fabiano with
40 seconds the the only thing you want
to avoid at all costs is the pre-move
here you never never want to pre-move
anything and here we go
rook and suddenly okay Rook G8 is still
a draw and it's still a draw precisely
because white has a B Pawn if White had
a c Pawn or a D- Pawn if you're driven
to the back rank like this you're losing
but because there is no left side of the
board this is a viable drawing strategy
here as well yeah and again not
convenient to defend this uh under time
pressure uh it's just not convenient at
all especially when all the
possibilities are being exhausted Naka
is going to try probably to move the
king and trade Rooks he could try since
Ty a king king to C7 Rook d8 con ruction
at the right moment but even there I
guess black will just trade Rooks and go
King B7 well what he's doing is building
up more time on his clock so that he
could milk it back down to zero and then
push B6 at the last second listen I'm
I'm sympathetic to to the fans here I
think there is a point at which it it is
fair to ask the question okay is milking
another minute off the clock really
going to impact the match that much you
know you're up by four on the other hand
if we're talking purely in terms of
match strategy and in terms of the best
thing to do to maximize your chances of
a win yes it is to do what he's
currently doing so you can't really
blame him for it so I'm getting word
from our uh our studio here that uh the
record is act for moves is actually
Nakamura versus so in 2020 it was 198
moves yeah 198 moves so I don't know
where we are right this moment but we're
surely getting close 70 we're at 170
this is hikaru's 170th move Rook A5 I
think we're going to get that record
especially if he decides to play Rook
versus Rook for another 50 moves we
absolutely could set the 200 move record
here oh my gosh I forgot he could just
jettison the B Pawn too and then go for
that oh my goodness totally but before
jettisoning it it he can keep it on B7
for a while
too this is wild this is crazy 176
moves and this is also probably the
longest in terms of the time I think I
think we're we're we're flirting with
the uh the record this game has taken
something like 10 minutes now 10 minutes
forth 3 minute game that sounds
mathematically impossible but it it's
not yeah the the the beauty of
increment sometimes the it's it's kind
of a a joy and a nightmare depending
upon which side of the the coin you're
on indeed you're on well I think most
people know which side of the coin I'm
on but here we see the downside of the
one second increment the body language
tells the whole the body language tells
the whole story here look at the body
language of the players on your screen
right now
well Fabby has only half of his face
visible yeah that's the slump in your
chair in dismay like I have to still
continue with this and I can't blame him
he's he's really played a much better
match than the score currently indicates
and it's not over but um it really has
been a few moments there's the record by
the way and he's gone Rook G6 he's
forced to draw 204 moves and Hikaru is
going to Wi these 20 seconds before
taking the r he's not going to move his
King and lose the game but he is going
to wait out the rest of his time and
finally make that
draw yeah and uh Fab's already got to be
thinking okay the game's about to end
what am i g to do next with my white
game how am I going to contend with this
A6 B5 business how am I gonna break that
down listen if they play 12 minute games
there might not even be time to play
another four games there's only 18
minutes remaining
in the threein segment this was the
longest game ladies and gentlemen in
history 203 moves 120 of them of course
came in that dead drawn Rook end game as
hearu tries to milk as much time off the
match clock as possible he holds a
four-point lead and it's finally time
for our quote unquote midpoint break
Casa yeah we say quote unquote because
of just how long that game was um but
yeah Naka is getting a little bit more
separation and we would like to see
Fabby probably send that t tide to
really Mak it a match going to Bullet
but it's tough this is these are the
best of the best so stay tuned stay
tuned indeed it's a four-point lead will
he car Nakamura take this match only one
way to find out we've got more chess to
be played in the SEC presented by
coinbase we'll be right
back
[Music]
God it's the same thing every time why
didn't you on assant bro I swear to God
on assant should be forced all my
friends watching in this day's taking
forever play faster if I could move this
Pawn backwards it would basically be
Checkmate oh and draws are dumb I should
be able to flag him no matter how many
times I repeat moves 1,400 years and
it's the same game every time you know
what it's time for some updates I'm
tired of this I'm I'm doing it still
mate is now a win for the player who
gets stalemated you're welcome Eric
Rosen hey it's the Rosen tra
pawns can move backwards why is that
never not been a rule pawns can move
backwards now every piece should be
allowed to on pant what that's not even
possible how ship it dunzo update enter
why is it ending there's just two kings
on the board what is this Purgatory this
is so awesome what we're doing here guys
we're changing chest why can't people
just move however they want whenever
they want
[Music]
wait what check bait do I not get to
move from now on C4 actually
[Music]
explodes pawns are weak no more pawns
can promote on the first move update
take that Ru I'm not sure I made the
users as happy as I thought I would
maybe chess doesn't need an update
Financial systems do need an update
though coinbase is working on just that
reenvisioning an entirely new Financial
system that is decentralized and fully
transparent thank you coinbase for
sponsoring competitive chess and making
events like the speed Chess Championship
possible go to coinbase.com updatethe
system today to learn
more he's I was here was I was lost okay
well hey eight let's go oh no I think I
should have just done that Chad I got 14
We Beat It
let's go no 15 unreal no first try eight
in a row nine in a row baby let's go
let's go I got a oh cool I got a little
achievement thing I honestly really
enjoyed that that was really cool become
a chess.com Community streamer at go.
chess.com slstart
streaming
[Music]
oh we have just worn witness to the
longest game in SEC history over 200
moves I see car Nakamura and Fabiano car
want to draw their latest game and
hikaro keeps a four-point lead in the
SEC match presented by coinbase here
alongside International Master Kasa
corle it's been a really entertaining
match thus far Kasa it's been a fun
match yeah yeah it's been really
interesting to see the the time
scrambles as we came to expect it's also
been fascinating to see uh basically
Nakamura widen the Gap in this segment
where Fabiano really needs to kind of
turn it up before the bullet portion he
has to turn it up on the board he's got
to turn it up on the clock and he has to
continue trying to punish shar's
openings not only in the early middle
game where he's done a great job he's
gotten the positions that he wants to
get but as the middle game draws on
Fabiano has missed his share of tactical
opportunities he's fallen behind on the
clock and those are some of the factors
that stand behind hikaru's big lead okay
here we go we're off Fab has the white
pieces in this next game and yet another
E4 A6 Owens kind of dragon St George
opening mixup I'm loving the version
Fabby has right now he had one of his
best positions in this bonon style setup
although you see here actually nakas
deviated by not capturing on D5 which
led him down really unfortunate path the
last time so a little bit of an
improvement here from Naka and uh we're
gonna we got an original position so I'd
expect Bishop G5 no releasing of the
tension again I'm not a fan of
this trading Queens but that means
you're not really going to punish
Black's King for losing castling rights
you don't have the Firepower to do so
Fab's idea is to push E5 and he's just
done that chasing the Knight back to D7
but this could also back firea that E5
Pawn is now very much vulnerable to the
move Knight C6 yeah and and black has
excellent space advantage on the queen
side in the long term and you know a lot
of these positions before we talked
about A4 you know breaking down the
black queens Side Pawn chain in previous
games here A4 could even be met by B4 in
some circumstances so I think black has
a pretty good version of these Queens
gamut accepted position positions you
tend to see it boggles my mind that that
Fabby traded queens and and went into
this end game voluntarily he is now flat
out worse uh he doesn't have the G5
Square so black is very uh free to
position his King on E7 get the Knight
out position it to C6 and potentially
the Knight could jump into D4 that's a
very very nasty idea it's not going to
be possible for the foreseeable future
but what is possible just go Rook ad d8
Knight B6 black has a million way to
improve his position yeah and I think
the reason Naka is holding off on
playing Knight C6 is because he might be
reluctant to play Knight to allow Knight
E4 hitting that dark Square Bishop
looking and maybe potentially sinking
your teeth into the D6 square with
Knight D6 so reluctant to play that I
think it's accurate what he's doing
right now making a few more prophylactic
moves before finally developing that
Knight yeah I'm curious actually now
that you you uh pointed out the
possibility of Knight E4 how he's going
to circum vent that and there's our
answer and he finds a really elegant way
to do that he goes Knight B6 and he
vacates the D7 Square for the other
Knight so I think he's going to go
Knight 8 D7 and potentially he can also
go Knight D5 and force this Knight off
the board and then the Knight could of
course come out to C6 and now the Knight
is on B6 B4 is actually a move that
might be legitimate at some point okay
opts for something else uh and yeah I
love Black's long-term potential here uh
with the space on the queen side but
tactically Fabby trying to stir the pot
a little bit Knight F5 check there was a
very nasty threat with uh the Knight
jumping into D6 that is why Hikaru
dropped his Bishop back to B7 Fabby
finds a way to finally finally solidify
the E5 pun so he doesn't have to worry
about that pawn anymore but what he does
have to worry about are some of these
weak light squares in the center the
Knight is heading for D5 for the
millionth time uh it seems I've kind of
lost track of which Knight that is still
feels like black is is a little bit
better but okay Fabby should be able to
hold this position I'm starting to worry
about his clock though yeah and I I hope
I'm not too prophetic here but I'm also
wary of just the vulnerability of the
g1a A7 diagonal towards the white king
also when you push the F Pawn uh much
further down the line the second rank
might be a vulnerability if the Rooks
ever uh ever get into into the position
and so I still love Black's long-term
chances here in a position that might
seem totally uh you know kind of
nothing special at first glance like
something like Knight D5 might you know
provoke G3 that might be worthwhile um
annoying you could also jump with the
Knight to A4 and he's done just that he
forces The Rook to abandon the defile
and now the move Rook d8 would really
press on this Knight also super
important the Knight on A4 guards the
bishop on C5 so it takes the sting out
of any potential discover checks how
about something like rook d8 in order to
induce C3 and then the bishop slides
into E4 forcing The Rook away from B1 he
does Bishop B4 first okay but this is
such a hard position to defend with only
45 seconds left yeah and it's it's kind
of funny because that Bishop takes on a
diagonal where it it doesn't have to be
evicted it can even slide back to H7
could be really elegant actually and uh
yeah the squeeze is on basically 30
seconds for Fabiano Carana he plays
Bishop F3 I think that's a good
defensive move he forces the bishop
trade okay technically hikaro could take
the Knight and then take the bishop on
F2 with check and he does so he tries to
to generate an imbalance a piece
imbalance which I think will help and
POS problems in Fab's time pressure yeah
no question I think right now it's going
to be so hard to deal with the Queens
side uh targets B2 and C3 efficiently so
Black's going to double here and start
to you know look at Rook D2 and bring
the Knight back to C5 clamping down on
some of these light squares of course
the D3 square has to be supervised by
White's Bishop at all time there go
hikaru's pawns Faby meeting fire with
fire playing B3 trading off the pawns
that Knight really is a Monster yeah and
it's funny because it's the dark squore
grip if it can be established will be
really menacing even though the bishop
also kind of simultaneously controls the
night squares jumping forward they're
both kind of asserting themselves in
different way the minor pieces that is
but it just feels like easier for black
to play well yeah the bishop controls
the Knight squares which also happened
to be the light squares B3 D3 and E4 are
all Under The Bishop's control and it's
that control which I think might allow
Fabby to hold this position together
B4 the Knight drops back to D7 and it's
going to reroute to B6 and potentially
to D5 from a practical perspective 20
seconds on the clock for Fabby he's got
his work still cut out for him but so
far he's doing a great job of keeping
his pieces active and keeping Black's
initiative at Bay and now blockading the
C Pawn can he play Rook C5 here Rook A5
even better and it must be said a while
ago Knight D7 was a winning attempt and
that's what I think is so you know cool
about you know how Naka handles his
business sometimes even when he's up in
the match is he's not he's really hungry
oh he's C3 he didn't take3 with that was
a
pin oh my gosh A6 white white is
probably still winning Knight C4 was a
was an inexplicable move but how do you
not take on C3 there Rook takes C3 was a
clear pin he must be Angling Bishop B7
Bish B7 but see you missed one of those
chances you miss one of those chances
against Saro and you don't know if
you're going to get another
one why King E3 why not King
E2 okay F6 now King to D3 and I still
think you should win this yeah no
question about it although Rook behind
the pawn it's going to be hard to push
to A7 conveniently King F5 King G4
generating counterplay on the king side
Hikaru doing Hikaru things in the time
scramble Bishop C8 holding the king
together King C4 King B5 oh he missed it
as
well oh my7 or KN C5 holds everything
Rook D4 and somehow there's no good
Discovery oh my goodness no come on but
that's crazy and this is goingon to take
a lot of time off the match clock and
let me tell you hear is playing this for
well not anymore okay now it's a
draw my goodness Rook takes C3 once he
missed that movea you could just sense
that the air had gone out of the
building he was winning after that but
it was never as
clean yeah and whoa
G5 connected passers what about
connected passers no this was a very
very very poorly played time scramble he
Carana is going to be kicking himself he
had a lot of chances there starting with
Rook takes C3 and ending just at the end
of that game with the move G5 not sure
if that was winning or not but you're
not risking if you're way you got to try
it yeah it's really really funny or
interesting to see Naka like shake his
head a bunch and then start the game
with Knight H3 because I see that move
and I shake my head so it's uh but he's
he's been getting away with it thus far
I have liked the way Fab's handled these
these positions on the black side going
for these early h4s um a little bit
different this time around though Fab's
played super high quality chess in the
opening in the early middle game but as
the game starts heading in the direction
of a messy time scramble position he's
missed so many of these of these one
move tactical chances and am I blaming
it for that absolutely not this is the
hikaro effect in action you kind of just
stop believing uh that a win could be as
easy as Rook takes C3 and your mind
starts playing tricks on you but the
overall level of Fab's play has been
exceedingly High and the only reason I'm
critical of his performance in time
scrambles is precisely because car
Fabiano Carana and nobody else we have
this king's Gambit style Dynamic with
the King on E2
and this beautiful Pawn Fen from uh C2
to G4 there I don't know what to make of
this in the short term but in the long
term you gota like White's pawns and G5
might also be something at some point is
white better
here
weird is white better I think white
might be better after G takes F5 black
is just kind of Frozen in place on the
king side and H3 is a a cute looking
Pawn but it's probably more of a
weakness than a strength at this point
for sure it's a Target in the end game
and uh you know if white is able to
consolidate you know maybe like Knight
D2 or Knight A3 a bishop D2 Bishop E1
it's gonna be all all all for
white very hard for black to make
inroads this pawn and F5 yeah as you
said it this Pawn chain is so menacing
and now black can't even sack a piece on
F5 because this Pawn is so well defended
yeah although it's maybe there's might
be some play on the G file now with
something like uh yeah yeah I was going
to say Tak and Rook G8 maybe there's
some Knight G4 but it's it's so hard to
break break in Knight B4 I like that
move Queen C5 piling up the pressure
yeah Queen C5 Bishop A4 pressure that C2
Pawn as much as possible there's Queen
C5 hikaro might have to drop his Knight
back to E1 I think that's the only way
to protect the pawn he's lucky to have
that move it's so reminiscent of Kings
Indian positions except normally it's
not the King on D1 it's the queen uh
whoa Knight G8 what are these retreating
KN moves yeah okay the bishop is
currently hanging he drops it back to
its initial Square I still like Bishop
A4 for some reason I would love to
provoke the Knight to B3 where I don't
think it stands very well or better yet
provoke the pawn to B3 either way I
agree he played placed the pawn on the
Knight on B3 on his own volition but
there was an extenuating circumstance he
got the darkk Bishops off the board and
again it feels like Black's initiative
has completely fizzled out maybe even G4
and G5 should be considered here yeah
and it's the trades the trades help
white who has the much weaker king or at
least did a few moments ago uh White is
probably going to look to just
neutralize that Rook on h8 trying to get
the Rook to H1 of the right
circumstance yeah just cover the entry
squares uh H1 H2 H3 and at some point
you're going to see some Rook H1 action
C3 C3 very very precise precise I like
that move a lot it chases the night away
it also gives white a better share of
the center okay wait now C takes D4 yeah
and that's that's another Pawn that's
another pawn and Fabby is trying to open
up the center to generate as much
counterplay as he can but the time
management we haven't even talked as
much about uh you know in the last set
of games but hikaro now is always up on
the clock in at least in the last couple
of games yeah and it's funny because so
I think in a lot of situations a lot of
people would just play Knight takes C6
automatically and try to trade and one
of the things that Naka does really well
is even when he is in an advantage
position he oh he's going to trade now I
was gonna say the trades don't always
help you keep the piece on the board
here you're activating blacks pieces
which is kind of why I thought he
wouldn't do this um yeah the queen is
off sides here that's the problem but uh
but he typically he does keep the
pressure on throughout and that's kind
of why why I was going to try and sing
his Praises there I feel like he's going
to go kn5 here that is a a really pretty
move because you're sacrificing F1 and
A1 but there's a Checkmate on A8 at the
end of it I wouldn't be able to resist
and neither does hearo yeah I think the
the lead also plays into it a little bit
here um but what does black do uh what
does black do Knight D7 only move in
order to cover the check on A8 with
Knight to B8 Fabby showing that he's got
a few punches left to throw and that is
not a correctly thrown punch King C2
apparently King C2 yeah King C2 Rook
takes A1 and then you start hunting
after Black's King with Queen A8 and of
course he found it and it's so hard yeah
Queen takes F2 I was gonna say that
geometry is not obvious it was not easy
to to understand that the queen was
covering F2 a few moves ago gosh that
that was troubling yeah he cannot catch
a break can
Fabby yeah all right I I love the start
to these games and we just got to be a
see it through but it's so much easier
said than done um all right so fivepoint
lead now for knockout with just four
minutes left in a three plus one
uh can we Castle here and then maybe get
a knight4 yeah but now feb's on til E5
was a bad move there he bit more than he
can chew in the center now he's going to
have to take on E6 again and and we had
this exact Pawn structure in the
previous game with these colors this
time it's an even worse version for
white because the Queens are still on
the board and Black's got a big big
space advantage in the
center yeah and the problem is if you
ever take on E6 knight4 is not happening
and so a lot of these positions actually
come down to this KN kn94 move and
whether you can get it in or you can't
and this is the second game in a row
where the answer is likely no although
he's trying to force it through with
Knight G5 rein yeah Knight G5 is a good
move I like Knight G5 I think he's
trying to to head back to E4 as you're
saying but Hikaru could ignore
everything just Castle the pawn on C4 is
such a an important Cog in Black's
machine because it's preventing the
White Queen from moving up to D3 and
exerting pressure on H7 instead hearo
delaying castling instead Knight D7 is
there Knight takes F7 no yeah I was even
looking at this bishop H5 theme again
trying to kind of provoke a weakness um
but I think it's it's uh not so
consequential yeah I'll show this on the
board for those who uh who are
interested why does Knight takes F7 fail
it's because after King takes F7 Queen
takes D7 looks like white is home scotf
free but white is not going to get home
after Rook a d8 the check on H5 is
easily disarmed by G6 and white simply
loses his Queen which is trapped and
look at the Rooks being connected here
it's not a coincidence that the tactics
work in your favor when you have a lead
in development and Harmony it just it
just kind of like this the unwritten
rules of Chess in in coming to the form
to coming to the fry well said and
instead Fabby playing Bishop F3 that was
The Logical followup to his previous
move and while he might get the light
sored Bishops off the board and that's a
good positional gain for white he still
struggles with the long-term weakness of
E5 and with the fact that black has this
very very pretty Pawn chain on the queen
side and potentially control over the
defile after a well-timed rook d8 yeah
so there are a number of options really
for Naka here he can um yeah he could he
could take on F3 he could uh but I
wouldn't I wouldn't develop the queen he
could go Rook d8 right away uh I mean
there's you're kind of spoiled for
Choice he could even Castle here crazily
enough for the same reason that Knight
takes F7 didn't work if he castles and
white plays Queen takes D7 you have to
flick in takes F3 but after Knight takes
F3 R A d8 it's exactly the same problem
the queen is trapped but yaru making the
less adventurous move he puts the Rook
on d8 can Fabby Garner kingside
counterplay with Queen H5 he's got to
try something like that yeah and it's
it's a good practical Choice uh
objectively you know who knows but
practically then getting those the
Knight E4 was the whole point of the
plan and you know sometimes you say like
a a bad plan is better than no plan at
all and you know getting getting this on
the board was
important yeah and it poses a bunch of
tactical threats the Knight takes E5
here runs into Knight takes C5 that is
the Tactical justification of White's
play because the queen on B7 will be
hanging suddenly Hikaru is kind of stuck
between a Ruck and a hard place here he
might have to Castle just because
there's no other good moves and then
you'll see Queen H5 yeah Queen a knight
F6 I mean then you have to reckon with
all sorts of tactics yeah
this might be the the the most
aggressive uh attacking position Fab's
gotten in a minute for sure and uh this
is the last game of the three plus one
segment hikaro holds a five-point lead
If he if Fabby wants any chances to come
back in the bullet which let's be real
are already very very slim but he's got
to try to end this segment with a
victory at least one Queen B8 is a
puzzling decision I must say but uh yeah
Queen H seemed automatic do you think
there was better than Queen H5 there
Queen F3 was possible but that would
have run into Knight takes E5 so yeah
don't know exactly what that would have
led to Knight F7 looks interesting here
four okay so he reinforces the pawn on
E5 probably we're going to see Bishop E7
as he Carwood tries to keep all of the
the dark squares around his King
protected and he's hanging by a thread
here but as the clock continues to
dwindle it feels like he's kind of
getting out of this bit by bit you can't
play H6 though because Knight takes E6
is just Thunders down so it's still hard
for black to you know consolidate and
F4 F4 F5 yeah I'm I'm even looking at
just Rook Rook D1 and Knight and Knight
D6 or some combination of of moves like
that totally or the immediate Knight D6
also looks great either way Fab's got to
make a decision fast and there we go
Queen B7 okay check is a threat Rook E1
Rook a one coming right up coming right
up this is yeah he he's he can break
down the construction with on E6 and
that will probably win the game if he if
he goes for this take it 96 rookie 6
King F7 rookie s rookie seven but King
G8 what's the followup there this is
what Abby has struggled with how about
Queen F5 and then Rook A1 that's sick
and queen E6 mate
possible Queen F5 ends it okay thiss
Knight F6 maybe keeps black alive
temporarily Queen D5 made in two yeah
and he finds it that's a huge win huge
huge win that is a huge win imagine if
Yaro had won that one it would have been
a six-point lead Four Points it's a big
lead it's a huge lead for someone like
Kar Nakamura but that was a great game
by Fabby he did exactly what he has to
do he played aggressiv he pounced on his
tactical opportunity and he capitalized
with accurate play in the Tactical low
time Skirmish he brings this deficit
down to four he's got 30 minutes of
bullet in order to come back
def but them with a victory in the final
game yeah and again sometimes it's when
you win that matters and ending the
segment uh with a win is huge just from
a momentum's perspective so you know he
can now lay it all out there and
hopefully be aggressive hopefully try to
stay up on the clock and you know
anything can happen anything can happen
Fabby will need all the energy that he
can get if he wants to come back in the
bullet before we go on a break speaking
of energy let's take a moment to thank
ag1 a new partner of the secc ag1 is
your daily support of key Health
functions for mental performance to the
energy that Fabiana Carana needs and the
immune system it's the one product that
does the work of many to find out more
visit drink a1.com or use exclam ag1 in
chat we thank ag1 for sponsoring the SEC
well we will give Fabiana Carana his
opportunity to drink some ag1 and
prepare for half an hour of bullet we
will be back with more speed chest
Championship action presented by
coinbase in just a couple of short
[Music]
minutes
four years chess kit has had lots of fun
online events but it's finally time for
us to go IRL in real life puzzle
competitions a main event and all sorts
of other fun things to do announcing the
chess kid national
festival come along you'll meet fun Neer
Mike there I'm going to the chess kid
Festival I'm going to the chess kid
Festival I'm going to the
[Music]
festival smell chess is coming to
chess.com
enchant your pieces with one of two
spells jump or freeze players start with
two jump spells and five free spells
which recharge after five moves you may
cast your spell whenever you wish before
making a regular chest move jump is a
spell cast to one square wherein if
there is a piece on that square other
pieces can jump over the Charmed piece
the freeze spell is cast over a 3X3
square area and the pieces in this area
are temp temporarily Frozen in place
combine your powers of Chess and sorcery
to defeat your
opponent come see what supercell and
chess.com have cooked up in our new
variant spell chess dropping on
September
1st
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the speed chest shage
presented by coinbase thear Nakamura and
Fabiana Carana duking it out in a
fascinating quarterfinal battle we had a
great match earlier today that was
commented by Hess and Bach you can watch
that on replay yand pomnish he stealing
that match over arjent aragi on the
strength of a last second Victory
International Master kasak Corley
there's no question that Grandmaster
Fabiana Carana has his work cut out for
him as we go into the
bullet yeah hakara widened his lead a
bit and uh he really flexed his muscles
in a lot of these scrambles and uh there
was just a lot of resilience shown even
in worse positions and Bob's going to
have to dig deep and show something
totally different in this bullet segment
well earlier Fabiano Carana said this on
facing hikaro hikaro is about as tough
an opponent as you can get that's a very
tough match I won't sugarcoat it in
terms of bullet he really is a monster
anybody with more than a nodding
acquaintance with the online CH
ecosystem knows that hikaro is a bullet
terrorizes the bullet field he's
obviously a legend across all time
controls but having to come back
specifically in a OnePlus One format
against Taro couldn't be more of a
nightmare
scenario yeah and we're going to
basically see H really the in the early
stages uh whether or not this is going
to be the making of the most incredible
comeback ever or whether it's going to
be something different so look for Fabby
to get get on the board pretty much
immediately if we're going to have any
discussion of comeback and I'm actually
not as worried about the speed as the
games get underway I'm not as worried
about Fabi speed I think Fabio Carana
2.0 ever since his large scale Blitz and
bullet Improvement he he's got the speed
he's fast enough I'm worried about the
Tactical opportunities that he's been
missing throughout the first two
segments because if you miss those same
types of opportunities in bullet then
the situation really becomes critical we
have at last a more conventional opening
in the first game of the bullet Hikaru
started with 1 E3 and followed it up
with kind of an English style
setup yeah and I do like Fab's position
I think I've said that a lot in a lot of
these games but it doesn't really matter
knight5 and Rook G2 to follow there's
tactics Galore on the Gile right now
okay Fabby is giving up a minor piece
for no compensation F takes C4 just
don't play Bishop takes
C7
is a problem that's not going to cut
it well at least he he resigns and he
doesn't try to play that out and let
more clock more of the clock milk but
that was not a great start here we go
into
London and hikaro pushing the early E5
that is one of the most reputable sort
of newish systems against the London
where black quickly liberates his center
with E5 and I think he solved all of his
opening problems now has hear Nakamura
finally transition to more conventional
opening play yeah I would actually
contend if you get the E5 breaking that
comfortably you're just slightly better
oh totally and uh particularly The
Exchange on G3 um it's it's actually
favors uh black in the long term uh I'd
actually go Knight F6 back here Knight
F6 back is a great move White's also
having some problems long-term problems
with the safety of his King right you
can't really go Queen side because this
Pawn is sticking out like a sore thumb
if you go King side black of course has
this class Pawn storm with H5 and G5
already on the board for hikaro yeah and
the the Saints are going to come
marching in right now H4 G4 after GH G4
the problem is after B5 just Queen C7
there's nothing going and so black is
hitting first and Fabius trying to open
up the B file but he's nowhere near
creating any semblance of threats on the
queen side hikaro opens up the G file I
think he's going to put a rook on G8 in
due course this is looking really Grim
once again for take that C5 Pawn I
wasn't that relevant yet I would have
gone Rook j a heartbeat but he's winning
and Rook dc1 two passive yeah Queen C
Queen H3 Queen C8 Queen H3
yes he's done it oh my good Exquisite
play by by
hikaro and to find that that quickly is
just disgusting totally
disgusting he's going to try and go King
H1 but there might even be some Queen H3
and then takes G3 and then Knight takes
G3 and Checkmate well Rook takes G3 is
is clearly a threat in this position I
think he can even do it in this position
Rook G3 can yeah and thenen H3 totally
crushing and we get the brilliant move
uh for that one but uh that one for
Nakamura is just par for the course
totally 94 check I think is even better
than promoting but you can also promote
oh hikaro is playing this with such
Precision k35 mate but a mate with a
Pawn on D5 holding the king's Escape
Square to C4 and a second Victory the
Domino's really starting to fall the
wheels the wheels have come off for
Fabiano caruana and it's just not a
surprise it's hear Nakamura in the
bullet time control yeah and now he's
going to get into this Kings Indian mode
which is frankly this is a much better
version of the of the Knight H3
positions he was getting earlier in uh
in previous segments so
yeah here we
go it it feels like hikaro has been
running in the mountains with like a
backpack on his back and now he's taken
off the backpack and started playing
conventional openings and now he's
actually crushing it out of the opening
yeah it's like yeah it's basically like
the the the Denver Nuggets you know when
they play home games you know the
altitude you know it just comes into
play well said Knight B6 Knight D5 yeah
and then F4 shortly thereafter never
really want to take this KN just because
it opens up the light Sor Bishop and all
these nice light squares uh the bishop
on G2 in particular huh Bishop C1 so
Rook takes D3 He wants Rook B5 which is
a really really nasty trap garu always
always finds these these weird geometric
constructions and fby sinking too much
time here on on on the retreating move
Rook A6 another Tempo move I'm surprised
F4 hasn't hasn't been isn't going to
come on the board but he's hassling the
black piece enough on the queen side
that it doesn't really matter yet we're
going to get a liquid a Black Knight on
D4 but black actually has a hard time
castling here I don't think Karo is
worse he's better yeah not not at all
yeah not at all Queen
A4 oh Queen A4 one of my
one when on Rook C1 all right F4
finally don't go Rook C6 yeah then Queen
F and F5 check oh gosh okay E5 is a move
here as his G I think hear is going to
recapture on F4 yeah why not then F5 E5
the Cavalcade of Pawns in the center
might just start marching takes to The
Rook okay 91 what a move 91 that is nice
Bishop F1 yet maintaining that Bishop
pair the 91 is it stuck Queen B noow
that Knight takes D3 is an idea
okay oh I think Rook I think Rook C1
there was actually really strong instead
of Knight C2 at some point he also had G
G7 G5 trapping The Rook on
F4 that is crazy now Bishop Bishop H4 is
going to
come all right it's fizzling out a bit
but uh there's still match clock to be
milked here and oh yeah as long as that
pawn does not get to A3 uh really no no
major problems will we get a 12-minute
bullet game no we we're going to get a
draw by agreement I thought he was
actually going to take on A8 play D5 and
then just chill with the bishop on the
diagonal for a long time for the
foreseeable future yeah
right all right this this has all been
seen before this San shedow grunfeld
stuff is not in this match but in In
classical chess a million times a really
nice practical practical try the C3
business all right do a bishop pair
White's got the bishop pair White's got
better control of the center but eard
just doesn't care he doesn't care what
the objective evaluation is he's so
confident in his ability to stir up
complications that you can give him any
position and he'll find a way to make it
interesting yeah Bishop a1's a good move
I think H4 H5 chisling away yep that
makes a lot of sense Bobby good call
chisel
chisel is D4
loose and he protects it takes with the
Knight but now his Pawn structure on the
queen side is a little bit damaged of
course black can push E5 at any point
but you got to be careful because then
the bishop on G7 is going to start
complaining he does it wow we're going
to get Mass Liquidation on the defile
will he pick up
C4 yeah yeah this Pawn structure on the
queen side was mangled not a not a
surprise a C4 Pawn falls off although
white is the bishop pair and the bishop
on G2 is really good so white should be
fine B7 is attacked Yaro could push B5
but then he has to allow a check on A8
this is an unpleasant position Black's
Knights are kind of suspended in midair
and he is going to go for this end game
slightly wor end game but I think might
hold this i' probably take on G6 sooner
rather than later I don't want to just
allow gh5 now in certain positions all
right Bishop all right this was a
serious winning chance for Fabby very
serious winning
chance well there's that gh5 move that
you were talking about later on black
can shatter away at White's kingside
Pawn H4 he plays E4 but Bishop B4 Bishop
B4 Bishop before still winning still
winning push him B push that a pawn
Bishop B3 would be a nice move keeping
the Knight Tethered to the F Pawn or
Bishop C6 as well and then A4 A5 let's
go King H3 now the Knight is paralyzed
and black will be progressively put in
zugang until he has to give up all of
his kingside pawns look at that
triangulation maneuver Bishop A2 Bishop
C4 and then Bishop D5 yeah okay he's
going after the H Pawn this is
completely lost yeah completely lost and
Naka will milk some match clock here but
this was a really nice game G by fobby
great control too he needs exactly five
more of those nice games if he wants any
chance of come back
here still not over all right G4 yep
that's that makes a lot of sense and
then mosy that King over King G5 King G6
mosy that King over King F7 there we go
and then King F6 and then you eventually
dart back to the E4 Pawn won't be able
to hold
both great call and he's going to make a
queen I would move the bishop though
I would get yeah the king is in a
perfect distance away I would not have
really touched the king there if I
didn't need to but okay we're going to
encircle the the Knight here okay and
maybe just Queen takes D3 just as a
sanity check yeah just because you never
know yeah these Knights like don't even
yeah just sack the queen come on no but
what hearu do oh E5 Knight E3 see that's
a case in point sack the queen just take
that Knight but there might might be a
Rosen trap with with like King A1 in
response to Queen takes C3 I've I'm a
big fan yeah but yeah yeah I hear you I
hear you these scare me a little bit
because you just need one Queen and now
let's ladder and now he car is gonna sit
sit for 40 seconds yeah now he's going
to sit for 40 seconds and that's the
reason why he was playing so fast he was
accumulating time via the one second
increment so that he can milk another 30
seconds off the clock and I love how
they just take they take Refreshments
while the stall Happ
snack
break all right well we have a 20 second
break Kasa in case you ever in case you
wanted to grab a snack or something yeah
yeah I'm gonna take a I'm gonna take a
swick
myself okay me too I've got two
different be three different beverages
in my desk but I'm out of coffee that's
a
tragedy all right see our job is very
easy yeah sometimes it is all right so
Five Point deficit still tough but keep
you just got to keep that momentum
going big shout out Rosen himself in the
chat no Rosen trap there but he did milk
a bunch of more time off the clock and
many have fallen for it so respect for
trying oh yeah all right so we got his
kind of B3 system where essentially
white gets what he wants which is play
against isolani potential hanging pawns
as well there's the transformation after
Beast tak6 now these hanging Pawns in
the DNC files and wow picking off A6 is
not does not happen every day and black
picks off A2 yeah you normally don't get
this position without the a puns and I
like the way Fabby he's playing actively
he's playing quickly and aggressively
this is how he needs to play but what's
going to be his followup the Knight
looks really pretty but it can be chased
away at a moment's notice with
H3 yeah and it must be yeah it must be
said okay Queen B3 was that the idea
Queen B3 five Rook A1 and black is in
trouble there on the queen side he might
drop his Bishop also Bishop B1 is an
interesting idea Bishop B1 and queen C2
Rook A3 though great move only move and
he's up a keeps his material advantage
for now all right
C5 whoa Bishop F5 Bang
King yeah and now this is turning a
little bit the the queen gets to H7 we
have a whole new set of problems he's
threatening that Bishop takes G4 and
queen H7 and if black takes the then the
Knight on G4 is stranded and look at the
clock situation jeez yeah 8 seconds us
ow Queen H7 there it is yeah Queen H7
yeah and
now1 H3 Rook D1 oh Knight H4 Knight
F5 oh my goodness swiss cheese man swiss
cheese on the king side it's over look
at those light squares and the bishon B4
is just a passive par maybe Rook A1 even
you have time for Absol absolutely great
minds think Alik Rook A1 Rook A7 he's
left himself with 40 seconds to figure
this out he gives a check on G6 and now
plays Rook A1 maybe C4 and Bishop B7
keeps black in the game and then Bishop
A3 just pinning again reinforcing the
pin forget it yeah this is
lost forget about it forget about it all
right so I would like to toss an H3 here
at some point it's not needed just yet
but oh
okay not yet uh and then and then Rook
A7 Rook A7 King E6 Knight f y King D que
takes and then Queen takes G7 we're
mating and there's no checks is what
you're saying okay hikaro wants to take
on G7 but with a check R E7 Rook A7 okay
and he's gonna trade everything and take
the Knight yeah or mate him or queen
queen f8 queen D6 also does the trick
that was a sick game yeah
yeah oh man
yeah I think he kind of I think Fabby
lost the thread when he with this Knight
G4 business it was aggressive but the
followup after there was after it wasn't
there uh all right we got a little
catalon action now Rook
D1 there we go yeah but wait this is
what whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa I would
with the Knight what is he doing he's
down a pawn and he's given up his fan
kto Bishop this is just terrible for
white yeah taking with the the Knight on
D4 is puzzling and again all these
trades just help black Rook C8 who whoa
whoa on e4 not sure about Knight takes
E4 there by Karo I thought he could have
just castled and kept the tension now
he's actually given white a serious
initiative in the center Fabby with a
great move and Knight F5 is super super
strong here yeah Knight F5 is certainly
incoming Castle Bishop H6 Bishop H6
Queen G4 Knight F6 Queen
H4 this is what Fabby needed more of in
the blitz oh
GF wrong move
order and Hikaru on F with the Knight
yeah two pieces for The Rook it's going
to be it's going to be Advantage black
all right Rook D5 double the Rooks try
and make some inroads but that n f8 is
covering a lot of business squares yeah
that's why you don't want to go Knight
G6 Rook D7 there would have skewered the
queen and the F7 Pawn now should be good
for black A5 solidifying the bishop
Fabby could infiltrate to the seventh I
play Queen E4 and H4 you need to
dislodge that knight from G6
totally
man it's crazy how fast this is going it
really is he's down he he's got over 45
43 seconds on his clock it's just insane
he's making high quality moves right
he's not just blitzing out random oh I
don't like Square hello swiss cheese
swiss cheese those dark squares again
okay he wants a well Rook dd7 though I'm
not buying it I'm not buying it I would
actually go I'd consider h H5 and then
Knight F4 or something like that but
Bishop D4 actually blocking The Rook
makes on the rook's access to D7 makes a
lot of sense great call now Knight F4 is
possible because Rook takes D4 runs into
Knight to E2 check all of the Tactical
details are taken care of Fabby should
Advance his King to G4 outside of the
checking zone of the king now it's too
late and now this King on G3 is in a
little bit of a mating net uh there
aren't a lot of squares if this Rook on
gets active it's it's Bish E3 Bishop E3
Rook D1 or Bishop C5
even Bishop D2 Bishop E1 was possible he
shuts down the Rooks it's over yeah yeah
and then Rook D2 yep he first solidifies
the E5 Pawn Rook D2 Rook G2 is winning
and Fabio resigns another game it's a
seven-point lead this is getting ugly
and it must be said it's so much easier
to talk about the Right Moves when
you're not in the heat of the action I
mean I just I can't say it enough in
this this time control I mean hikaru's
form across the board across the time
controls has been ridiculous I mean we
see this in bullet brawls right when you
catch him on a Saturday when he's gotten
his sleep and he's at home and he's in
good
form nobody can stop I mean the guy just
wins game after game with 50 seconds on
his clock at the end of it and that's
with no increment yeah I mean it's it's
just it's
traumatic that's basically what it is so
it really is
um Okay so we have some potential
battery maybe A4 and queen D3 now
actually and here we go the bishop this
is this is a problem uh uh Knight E5
maybe or E4 and queen E3 interesting
Knight B4 now Queen
E3 plays it immediately okay we get it
in the other
order all right this Rook one wants to
get into the game and because it's not
black is actually okay although
practically speaking it doesn't look fun
all right A5 here I would there's no way
I'm moving that Knight um I'm just going
to play A5 pinning I wouldn't pin myself
like that but okay Knight E5 Rook
F2 okay Bishop takes E5 is possible yeah
black there's got to be an inroad here
for black maybe Rook C
no all right now I like white look at
those Bishops those are nice Bishops in
my opinion I mean okay D4 is extremely
strong you can't take as a rook C1
wow Bishop F7 now you can take on D4 but
no you can't still can't take on D4
because the H2 square is protected Bobby
trying to stabilize that Bishop H7 check
was possible there oh my gosh car is
starting to run a muck with his Bishops
yeah and the worst is over for Naka and
again 45 minutes to 20 seconds problems
rooky won
yeah worst is over Best Is Yet To Come
Bishop G said
o goodbye another game I mean 45 seconds
on the clock at the end of it that tells
you all you need to know yeah and again
you got to appreciate just the the speed
with which and with which he recognizes
opportunities that's really what it
comes down to it's it's the the
recognition is so instantaneous at
times yeah I think there's a story about
an old an old IM leavon alunan who uh
was watching hiar
in a tournament in Arizona when Hikaru
was still an international Master which
was around the you know the Civil War
era like you dinosaurs were still
roaming the earth when that was the case
and he he checked out one of fukaru
games and he came away and told my
friend in like a thick Russian accent
his computer he's just computer and you
can see that here Hikaru is just in in
bullet I think you see it more than in
any other time control the ridiculous
amount of accuracy that is displayed in
the the span of just a couple of seconds
yeah I do like what Fab is doing here
trying to kind of by Brute Force mate on
the H file and it seems to be working um
but again now Naka is gonna think for 10
15 seconds and come up with something
that's gonna be practically challenging
Bishop F6 is that the that thing I think
it is I think he gets himself that dark
squ pish but F4 e54 oh he's allowed E5
no no no no no no now this King is it's
white is lost yeah the bishop on D3 is
cut it's totally out of game after
Knight takes C5 white is lost Bishop G3
check I mean look at White's position is
suddenly in shambles Fabby had to be the
one to push E5 he delayed it by one move
and now his only chance I think is to
orchestrate counterplay on the H file
but Kasa the instructive thing is that
as long as the h8 square is defended by
Black's Bishop there's never going to be
any problems like Queen H7 check is not
dangerous at
all yeah yeah 100% as long as that that
that fien shadowed Bishop is covering
that corner square that corner coffin
you're in good shape and now we see wh's
King is gonna get checkmated Queen F
Knight E3 all that Bishop is a hero that
Bishop is a defensive hero okay Queen F4
check was possible Rook B8 Rook B2 it's
a massacre on White's King just a Massac
Kevin Durant would tell that Bishop
you're the real
MVP so uh yeah it's uh it's it's
problems Queen
F4 wait a second I think hearu played
that move Queen F4 but it was one move
too late he L fabby's Knight Rook get to
E1 Bishop C4 Bishop C4 F7 is hanging
Bishop B6 Knight takes C6 I think white
suddenly winning no you can't play
Knight takes
C6 and then Queen A8 King G7 Bishop
takes e apparently the move is Bishop
takes C6 oh
wow yep oh it's it's all with check
that's why the Bish take the
bishop whoa K Queen takes C3 oh no and
Rook H1 now is winning oh he put it made
Queen E3 queen queen E3 is made Queen E3
Queen
D2 oh my God the bishop on F6 was
hanging oh that was that was a he buy
one he cannot buy one it's crazy how did
he lose that it's hard man it's hard you
know like I I mean you know God you know
I know we definitely know and that's
what I I tell myself every time I lose
to hikaro from a position where you have
to find the only moves you know the only
path and you manage to do it game after
game after game that's just what hearu
does to and you got to feel feel it for
Fabby I mean he just can't buy one right
now and that's just what iaru
does yeah and this n on D1 is not great
he's winning again I mean he crushing
your car out of the opening and he's
been doing that the whole match but look
watch this KN become go on a hero's
journey and something something happen
this Knight we'll get to C5 and then B3
and then it'll take on D4 and oh wait
and now the Knight is coming to C5 and
now you can't go G5 yourself I don't
think black is even better anymore not
at all and now Knight C5 Knight B3 whoa
that's a excellent practical attempt I
must say you have to try and shake
things up that's awesome but I would
have played eakes F6 with hearu I like
what Fab's doing here these pawns as
intimidating as they look Kaz you're
right they're actually blockaded by
Black's bishop and you could try to pick
them off with Rook e eight and D4
another excellent move cutting the uh
cutting off the opportunity for white to
play D4 and hold all those pawns
together this has turned a little bit
now Rook F5 is incoming another I mean
great stretch of moves by Fabiano Carana
but can he finish it off 55 seconds for
hikaro he chases the Knight away he
takes on E5 check he can do it now why
G3 I think it's because of Queen G3 and
Fab is not sure if this end game is all
that good for him and I can't blame him
Rook F4 though was a great
move Rook
G8
yeah yeah Rook Rook G8 Rook G8 if you
take it there's Rook G4 he's G Rook h8
that might be a mous slip Knight G5
there's got to be tactics now yeah
Knight G5 and then Queen takes a four
and then the F Pawn will decide the game
oh Rook e four is win he car is going to
win this one too isn't
he he's got twice that yeah we he's won
again it's a 10-point match oh
gosh oh
no this is this is the games have turned
dramatically in the middle game
dramatically it's just crazy the
turnaround speed you know even in the
last game he dropped an exchange for
what seemed like no compensation his
Knight on D1 was completely out of the
game five moves later it looks like it
it came from a completely different
game yeah I think that the the instinct
is just to consolidate when you have
these advantages and it feels like
somehow some way when you try to
consolidate you actually give
opportunities along the way that's just
how it
feels yeah and we saw that earlier in in
the five as early as the five minute
segment I think we saw the narrative
unfolding that Fabby got good positions
out of the opening sometimes winning
positions out of the opening given
hikaru's incredibly offbeat choices but
then a little bit too much hesitation
sometimes a little bit too slow
sometimes a little too passive and the
moment you let hikaro back in the game
he's not going to leave until he
extracts at least half a point out of
you yeah I was going to say I'm a little
surprised the the the got gave up the
light Square Bishop there I was
anticipating a G3 King G2 Dynamic but uh
but yeah this
uh I'm I'm not so sure I like Fab's
position anymore uh things are a bit
loose and the 94 is actually pretty
stable takes look at that tactic
wow wow if what's he gonna do if Bishop
takes
G7 uh Bishop takes C3 maybe yeah I was I
was seeing that I was like what a
mess now he's just up a pawn this might
be another one for hikaro and he has he
can just go King h s this king's just
going to be very snug whenever it needs
to
be now the A4 Pawn is also a long-term
weakness White's position starting to
crumble I think he could probably grab
that pawn on demand yeah it's just
consolidating before he does so because
he has so many improving moves King H7
again just keeping that King Totally
Secure and now he might dance with the
queen a little bit maybe Queen D7 Queen
H3 no okay Dees to go for
it back to C five
yeah I was actually wondering if D4
there was good intermediate now he
pushes A4 so that if white goes Queen C6
for example Yaro could actually take the
queen and the pawns will promote
simultaneously A3 yeah and again you're
going to have two passes on the CN D
files as well to work with after those
those Queens come on all right this
one's over C4
extending the contact between the queen
of the pawn he takes another pawn and
now C3 or even A2 yeah Queen C5 very
classy just pinning the B Pawn not
allowing it to be pushed 11 points and
we have time probably for two more games
I would imagine the the way that these
games are going we might even have time
for three given how how little time
hekar was spending on his
moves yeah I mean it's in in the
blistering speed is just incredible
incredible and the Precision I mean it's
hard to play this well this fast uh
period
perod I mean that's genuinely what makes
Yaro a terrifying SEC opponent you know
even if you have like a five-point lead
going into the bullet you can see what
he did to Fabby here in the bullet
segment and it almost feels like he's
been coasting that's the scary thing so
no lead is safe against Saro if he holds
a lead going into the bullet you're
basically screwed and it's another
perfect example like the opening has
gone pretty well uh you know you have
excellent Bishops you have a a safe for
King but look watch Nakamura hustle uh
this out and start to improve it keeps
happening but I love this move Bishop C8
trying to aming Great maneuver and now
you can play Bishop takes D4 and queen
C6 and you've got these massive holes on
the light squares there is no mate
threat I think after Queen C6 because
the G2 square is
protected I wouldn't have actually Tak I
would have gone Bishop B7 and queen B7
and kept my dark Square Bishop a little
longer CU if you don't have mate you're
going to start start to feel frustrated
and I think he's already feeling
frustrated white can drop his Queen back
to F1 and smoke out Black's Queen from
F3 he's doing just that looks like hearo
has great holding chances here and maybe
even more Bishop F3 to contest the file
oh no Bishop C5 happens
first yeah and again the position is
turning turning a little
bit
yep Queen
E2
all right H3 just covering some more
light squares B4 and A3 B4 A3 oh my
goodness there have been some very very
bright spots for Fabiano Carana he's
found really really cool ideas
throughout the match it's just come too
few and far between and watch shikaru
continue to complicate this game can he
pick up the pawn on C4 is my question
and what is Black's response to that
move going to
be probably still
A3 just tuck the King on h
s by the way this will be the last game
of the match the match counter is
running out yar's clock is also running
out as he plays Rook C2 there's A3 Fab
should be able to take this one Bishop
E4 there we go Rook B2 Bishop D3 Rook A1
is a beautiful way to finish the game
yeah and then queen2 Queen E1 mate all
right we want we want you to finish this
one Fabby show us Rook A1 that's the
cleanest win it's not just a flashy move
it's the only way to win cleanly because
if you check on G2 there's Queen of2 and
he's got it he's got it and a beautiful
game to finish off the match a good
consolation win but ultimately the
result of the match has not been in
question now for a very long time and
Nakamura acknowledges it as well I think
we should all give a golf clap to that
move because it it is it deserves it
it's it's a pretty finish
so well what what a
match what a match the final score is
185 to 8 and a half basically the same
number with the addition of a small
little number in the T place for hikaro
Nakamura he takes care of business he
advances to the semi finals and despite
his Ultra offbeat opening choices
despite a host of really dubious
positions across all three segments the
result of this match I don't want to say
was never in question but let's be
honest just didn't have enough tactical
Acumen he didn't have enough speed and
although he played inspired solid
professional chess it's not enough to
beat an on form yaru
nakamuraa yeah and let's be clear fabbi
is a a tactical Beast one of the best
calculators in the world it's just in
these fast time controls you have to
read and react over and over and over
again and Nakamura just showed us
another level of doing just that he did
indeed he really kicked it into a a
different gear in the final segment in
the bullet he really pulled away and
ultimately he wins the match with a
doubl digigit lead okay don't go
anywhere folks we will have hkar
Nakamura on for an interview and we'll
have the Savvy move of the day for you
when the speech Championship presented
by coinbase returns in a
[Music]
few
just played an exciting game and want to
see or maybe where you could have
improved check chess.com game review is
just a click away game review is a fast
fun and instructive guided review of
your games see your accuracy and your
opponent's accuracy check out the eval
graph for an instant overview and scroll
down to see how many great moves best
moves blunders and yes brilliancies you
have played learn from chess.com coach
who gives move explanations opening
statistics and shows you the best lines
of play
with retry mistakes you can get another
shot at finding missed opportunities try
game review today on web iOS or Android
September Bots are here and it's time
for a Monumental Clash this Barbarian
might not Crush you on the board but he
certainly can Crush you with the board
speaking of crushing this giant is a
living Siege Tower usually found in
groups goblins are fond of shop pointing
objects and other people's
pieces the battle Harden Valkyrie might
give you a game once she's done arm
wrestling a
Golem this hog rider and his Noble Steed
might give you a headache or two
skeletons adore her POS FEA you'll need
to bring your aame if you want to beat
this witch yes that probably is a rabbit
up his sleeve or a huge Fireball with
your name on it we hear Wizards are
pretty good at chess
not just a killing machine Pekka loves
tiny butterflies but you're probably not
a butterfly so watch out the Archer
Queen thinks highly of herself and for
good reason she is a skilled tactician
deadly opponent and your worst nightmare
play them all on chess.com
[Music]
n
this
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the speed chest
Championship presented by coinbase we
have Grandmaster hikaro Nakamura in the
studio who has won his first two SEC
matches both by double digits hikaro
thank you for joining for a quick
interview congratulations on taking care
of business today this was a close match
until it suddenly wasn't what was the
turning point of the match for
you well I mean there there many there
many things that I could say about this
match I think I think first and foremost
Fabiano held firm at the start I mean
there there were quite a few games that
could have gone either way um you you
know to be fair the first game could
have also gone the other way I think
Fabiano got up to a good start when I
blundered this Rook D1 move I played
Rook A1 Queen C4 Knight F Knight F
Knight F5 first without Rook D1 or queen
F1 I think I would have won that first
game um you know putting the first game
aside I mean I thought Fabian played
well in the five plus one I think it's
mainly that he found himself down going
into three plus one um and for the most
part I felt that fob was getting very
good positions out of the opening and
and essentially just didn't have enough
time to convert them plus one so the 3
plus one it's only going to be magnified
even further and I think the fact that
he was down after the five plus one at
that point was already going to be very
difficult for him to come
back yeah hakara you played a lot of
these kind of Owens defense hybrid
setups combining A6 and then E6 and when
you when it goes when when you decide to
play these setups that are offbeat do
you consider how long it'll take for
your opponent to be accustomed to to
kind of solving the problems in the time
control and then figure that you'll
it'll be just be a little bit too much
time for them to kind of solve the
problem well you know there's this
certain player the a certain former
world champion who also does the same
thing maybe not maybe not as often but
um you know Magnus has done quite a bit
of this too with this A6 A3 stuff and
playing I think he played some like d D6
Knight F6 H6 stuff I think against me
actually um in an event not so long ago
um I I think the main thing is it's a
very difficult balance between using
your time to like sort of try and punish
your opponent out of the opening when
they play something dubious versus
playing practical and I think you know
certainly for faan he was trying very
hard to punish me out of the openings
and I think of course you know a slow
game he probably would have been able to
but in the fast games he wasn't quite
able to do it and then he was always
struggling on the clock is what it felt
like so um I don't think you're ever
going to be truly a custom but you
probably noticed that after the first
set of playing I think C3 playing the
Saragosa opening I started playing
Knight to H3 on move one and the reason
I did that is because since the breaks
have gotten so long thanks to needing
needing to run ads um I was a little bit
worried that maybe Fabiano would go like
go talk to leavon and and come up with
some something to do against it which is
why I switched over to Knight
H3 do you think it's fair to say hikaro
that these offbeat openings also produce
a psychological effect on the opponent
especially when you know toward the end
of the match Fabby was actually getting
worse positions with white out of E4 A6
do you think that's partially because he
was starting to get tilted at his
inability to to punish these lines
effectively
well I mean I think just the match score
was the the biggest problem you know
I've said it before and I'll say it
again um when when I play these matches
in the SEC I feel like in general I'm
I'm a huge favorite in one plus one the
final portion of the match against
pretty much everybody except for maybe
Magnus oi res and I guess ding I I
actually ding ding played really really
well against me I think it was two years
ago um and I think that you know at the
end of the day um the fact that I have
that big Edge it puts so much pressure
on my opponents I think Fabiano as soon
as he start losing at the start of three
plus when he fell down by three or four
he knew he was going to be behind going
into the bullet and so I think it's more
just like you start becoming
disappointed and depressed and and for
me honestly having been on been on the
right side I mean of many of these
lopsided matches I think at some point
it also becomes very difficult to play
for me too because like you just want
the match to end you're you're not
really in it you just want the whole
thing to just be over with on both sides
um so yeah I think for Fab he got worse
position he couldn't crack and it's like
what am I doing what am I supposed to do
you just like mentally start going in a
bad
Direction
yeah I'm going to actually ask a
question from uh the chat actually
wanted to know someone that chilled
liven want to know what did the finger
signify that you held up to the camera
at some point there's
there right yeah thank you thank you for
asking that question yeah so you know
there are a lot of people who seemingly
have uh have long-term memory loss first
of all or they just haven't been in
chess for a very long time and I know
people are going to be mad at me for
saying this um but you know I noticed in
in the comments a lot of people were
saying why am I stalling why am I
running down the clock why am I running
the clock down and um you know it's
worked very well for me over the years
there's a reason I do it it's because
you have less games I felt in in five
plus one and three plus one faon chance
are better than one plus one but that
being said you know at the end of the
day Fabian is very strong player and you
know even if I think that maybe 90% of
the time I'm gonna have a good day if
I'm down if if I'm let's say I'm up by
four games going to the one plus one or
up by one game if Fab is having a great
day and I'm having a bad day fa Ono
could take me in the bullet portion and
win the match so uh that's why I started
running the clock down just to try and
reduce the percentages of losing the
match and then secondly as far as the
finger it's because um the game against
fa on where I did that I believe that's
one where Fabby played Rook A8 forcing
the trade of the Rooks into the
bishopman pawn end game and I could have
also milked the clock there I could have
taken another like one one and a half
minutes maybe not one and a half minutes
but I think we both had about 30 seconds
I probably could have taken at least
another minute off the clock then I
didn't do it and of course the best part
about that is when I didn't do that in
the very next game I got steamrolled um
and I lost so you know I think it's it's
kind of fitting um that for for all the
people who are busy saying that like I I
don't follow the correct strategy in
that game in the bullet portion because
I felt that it was already sort of Out
Of Reach and then I then I get smoked in
the next game so uh it's kind kind of
fitting in a way um so yeah that's
that's what it was about it's like I I
think I said like this one time that's
what I that's what I said to the camera
uh very
specifically and I must just just
quickly point out here that you did
today produce the longest game in SEC
history in that that filor position that
eventually turned into a stalemate with
a rook G3 it was a 200 plus move
game yeah I could have sworn that when I
played har Christian a couple years ago
there were probably two or three games
that were like that which went on
forever but but again maybe maybe I'm
just forgetting things um but but yeah
that that being said I think you know
um it's Magnus has done the same thing
too I think that mainly for me I feel
like in bullet that's my bread and
butter I think I I think Jan best
probably in three plus one and one plus
one specifically against Fabiano and
it's trying to just reduce the number of
games and um and also the other great
thing is like I did notice the clock and
I think at the start of that game there
was something like 31 minutes and so by
keeping the game game going on forever I
knew they would we would then hit the
seven minute ad break as well and
Fabiano would draw the game and I
figured mentally he would not be in a
very good mood so it always kind of kind
of worked
outar one final uh chat question before
we let you go you're streaming uh from
Works drill and I'll modify this
question a little bit to make it more
suitable for NCC context we already know
who are the top two bullet players
obviously presumably you and Magnus who
is number three and who would you say is
number three in a one plus one time
control yeah so I mean this is a very
tricky question I think a lot of people
underestimate the difference between one
plus one and 1 plus zero you know you
can't just win games on time and and
actually Fabiano today when I was
playing him he there were many many
situations where he just moving too
quickly trying to play the first 20 25
moves in one second or less when he
could have used his time more so one
plus one is very very different um I
honestly want to say I mean out of of
course i' I've played many matches in
the SEC I mean ding has definitely put
up the biggest fight in one plus one
outside of Magnus when I played him so I
mean it's only one match but I'd
probably have to S Say ding just based
off that outside of ding um I mean maybe
I would say knall maybe knall is
improved but just out of all the people
I've played d was by far in a way the
best player in the onpl one that I face
outside of Magnus Carlson um without
without a doubt he was he was easily the
strongest
player that makes a lot of sense well
hikaro we will let you get back to
streaming that was a super entertaining
match congrats uh on defeating your
compatriot and have a great rest of your
stream good luck in the next
match thank you guys have a good one bye
take care you
too okay another match in the books
another quarterfinal in the books that
means we have two left hassa and this
one was a blowout I think as often
happens the final score didn't really
reflect the way that the match went it
took a lot of big moments from hikaro to
actually finish off his opposition yeah
no question about it the score the final
score was not indicative of how close
this match was for a big stretch of it
and uh yeah kudos to hako for doing hako
things it was really impressive it was
indeed speaking of very impressive it's
time for our Savvy move of the day
presented by coinbase and it took a lot
of tactical Wizardry by Hikaru to
ultimately knock his opposition off and
one of those moments came in a game in
which hikaro was up in exchange Fabby
missed a winning move earlier it still
looks very dangerous for Hikaru but in
this position he found a really lovely
liquidating idea in this position he
pushed the pawn up to E4 hitting the
bishop and seemingly blundering his own
Bishop now the idea is simple if white
plays Bishop takes E4 then black forces
uh the exchange of queens and gets a
winning endgame Fabby was forced to take
the other piece the bishop on D4 Hikaru
takes on F3 with check removes Fab's
Bishop from D5 and now gets this queen
over to D5 blockading the Knight winning
back the D6 pawn and ultimately reaching
a technically winning position that
hikaro was able to convert that was a
pivotal win for Hikaru Nakamura and E4
is our Savvy move of the day presented
by
coinbase and that Casa corle is
essentially All She Wrote what a match
oh my goodness I mean it was just there
are fireworks from the beginning it it
was just a lot going on and just the
Precision even with seconds essentially
was what separated these two greats
these two great of American chess these
two greats of you know chess in General
on the world stage uh just the Precision
under time pressure Precision is the
word of the day their highest accuracy
both 97% their average accuracy
relatively similar again this doesn't
really tell the whole story of the match
but it was a combination of speed it was
a combination of Hikaru karan's
inability to punish some of Hikaru
nakamura's dubious openings as well as
hikaru's unique his unparalleled ability
to pose serious problems to his opponent
and on that note folks our double header
today comes to an end before we wrap up
the show we wanted to remind you of what
month it is it is the middle of
September in twitch terms it's called
the middle of September we wanted to
remind you that through the end of this
month you can claim up to 30% off on all
new Subs on Twitch subscribers gain
access to exclusive Breaktime content
during broadcast unlock new emotes and
score and AD free experience on
chess.com do not miss out on the deals
for the remaining two weeks of this
subtember subscribe right now and on
that note folks it's time to wrap up our
broadcast Kasa it was a great pleasure
to commentate with you today I'll throw
it back to you for your final thoughts
before we end for today da it was such a
pleasure commentating with you today
folks thanks for watching uh we have an
incredible slate of SEC matches coming
to you soon and so stay tuned there's
more to come there is more to come we'd
like to thank our amazing production
team who makes our job easy everybody in
the chat cheering on your favorite
player the SEC is the most fun event of
the year and on that note another day of
the speed chest Championship presented
by coinbase comes to an end we will see
you for another set of awesome matches
tomorrow so
[Music]
long
n
[Music]
w
[Applause]
[Music]